[Musique]
bonjour
bonjour à tous est ravie de vous
retrouver sur public sénat ce matin les
auditions de la commission d' enquête
sur la crise sanitaire se poursuivre
vous le savez créé en juillet dernier la
commission a pour objectif de tirer des
leçons de cette crise du coville
déterminer ce qui a fonctionné et
évidemment sur tout ce qui n'a pas
fonctionné depuis le début de l'été la
commission a auditionné notamment des
présidents de région des professionnels
de santé des élus des associations de
patients et ce matin on s'interroge sur
le contexte international
les sénateurs se penchent sur la
situation en république de corée
je vous propose de regarder ces échanges
et on se retrouve après mes chers
collègues nous poursuivons donc nos
auditions ce matin avec une audition
très particulière consacré à la gestion
de la crise en république de corée
bien sûr je vous présente les excuses du
président milon qui est retenu dans son
département et nous allons entendre ce
matin monsieur young man show y
ambassadeur de la république de corée en
france et monsieur philippe lefort
ambassadeur de france en république de
corée la corée a elle aussi été
confronté à une éruption violente de
l'épidémie en février dernier comment
grant est un rassemblement religieux a
été à l'origine de nombreuses
contaminations mais la comparaison avec
la france doit s'arrêter là le pays a
mis en place une stratégie de test
massive de contact racing de fermeture
précoce des frontières de distanciation
sociale et de port du masque qui a
produit semble-t-il de bons résultats en
matière de tests le pays est devenu un
des premiers producteurs mondiaux de
kits de dépistage
nous avons donc souhaité consacrer une
édition retour d'expérience coréens sur
la gestion de cette crise sanitaire et
je vais donner à nos intervenants un
temps de parole d'environ 10 minutes
avant de passer comme il est de
tradition aux questions des rapporteurs
puis de nos commissaires et conformément
à la procédure des commissions
denquête je vais demander philippe
lefort de prêter serment jeu philippe il
est en vision très bien voilà vous le
voyez pas ce que moi je ne vois pas
monsieur le sénateur même si très bien
et bien monsieur lefort prêté serment de
dire la vérité toute la vérité levé la
main droite et dit je le jure je le jure
merci alors je vous rappelle bien
entendu que le port du masque est
obligatoire je vous remercie pour votre
vigilance et nous allons commencer par
monsieur l'ambassadeur de la république
de corée
en france vous avez la parole monsieur
le président mais pour sa part j
mesdames et messieurs les rapporteurs et
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs
on va s'arrêter les bleus fort un bon
jour à tout d'abord c'est un grand
tournant pour moi de participer à la
commission denquête du sahara ce matin à
cette occasion que je voudrais vous
expliquer ce que la corée du sud à faire
pour endiguer la crise sanitaire
ces derniers mois l'objectif de ma
présentation est le partage
d'informations ainsi n'est ni un
jugement
niveau communication le premier cas
confirmé a été reporté a souvent bien
mais la situation a soudain commencé à
se dégrader
fang févrière la corée du sud est par la
suite devenir le deuxième pays le plus
contaminé par le virus après la chine de
nombreux pays ont alors averti leurs
populations sur les risques de voyager
on courait quelques pays sont allés
jusqu'à fermer leurs frontières aux
coréens
sept mois plus tard aujourd'hui encore
est le bilan s'élève à 21 milles
400 cas confirmés et 342 c'est donc jean
pays qui compte 52 millions d'habitants
grâce à sa gestion de la crise sanitaire
la corée du sud a pu éviter un
empilement total les élections
législatives se sont tenues mi-avril
sans encombres la corée du sud n'a
jamais fermé ses frontières aux troupes
et selon le rapport de l ocde publié il
ya deux semaines l'économie de la corée
du sud devrait se contracter cette année
mais de manière limitée - giro burili 8%
j'aimerais maintenant évoqué la façon
dont mon père a agi pour éviter une
dégradation de la situation depuis 2000
l'accord a été frappé par une série
d'épidémie et qui n'ont que très peu
touchés du raw est telle que le saas le
h1 n1 le h5n1 et enfants de metz en 2015
assure la base des leçons tirées de
chaque épidémie
le gouvernement a mis en place des
mesures principales en 2015 une loi pour
mieux réagir à de futures épidémies a
été votée à l'assemblée nationale elle
permet notamment aux centres de contrôle
et de prévention des maladies ou cassés
décès agence indépendante créée en 2004
de voir ses ressources financières et
humaines pour monter paris vers le rôle
des gouvernants locaux est primordial
sur le tour en l'air jason ont été de
véritables soldats sur le front de la
lutte contre les épidémies
un nouveau système de collaboration
entre le gouvernement central est les
collectivités territoriales a alors vu
le jour face à la robuste isin
fr0004163111 test traçage et traitements
dès le début de la crise sanitaire et
avant
même que le premier cas soit confirmé en
cours et le gouvernement et des
entreprises de biotechnologies locales
ont commencé à travailler ensemble sur
le développement d'un type de test un
mois plus tard nous avons atteindre une
capacité de dépistage allant jusqu'à et
40 minutes par jour où la seconde étape
a été de faciliter l'accès aux tests
ambiance 600 centres de dépistage un
public et privé ont été rarissimes
obligé pour les personnes présentant des
symptômes ainsi que pour les cas de
suspicion de contamination qui a
instruit station de test mobile ont même
été aménagé permettant aux conducteurs
de l'effectif sur place sont sortir de
leur véhicule est les cas confirmés sont
étroitement signés par l'égypte enquêtes
épidémiologiques qui a cédé c'est le cas
c'est de cibler les données relatives
aux déplacements des cas confirmés
mais selon l'accord ou le 112 des
personnes potentiellement concernées
n'ont pas pu être identifiés ces données
sont collectées au moyen d'outils
numériques variés comme les historiques
de transactions de carte de crédit
la vidéosurveillance ou les données gps
téléphone portable ça seychelles je
voudrais souligner que cette lancée
d'hier a été mise en place sur la base
de la loi adoptée par consensus à
l'assemblée nationale coréenne en 2015
l'assemblée nationale avait alors
consulté des experts des associations et
bien sûr l'opinion publique
cela explique l adhésion des coréens à
la loi considérée comme étant au service
de l'intérêt commun à double hélice
toutes les informations collectées sont
gérés et contrôlés dans leur intégralité
de manière à les négliger al honi j'ai
donc respect des lignes directrices
fixées par la commission nationale des
droits de l'homme
après utilisation ces informations
sont détruites par les autorités son
délai sur la base de chaîne de
contamination est vérifiée et rendue
publique par le cas cdc des entreprises
privées développe et diffuse des
applications destinées à la population
grâce à ces applications les coréens ont
la possibilité de vérifier s'ils ont
fréquenté les mêmes droits que des
personnes contaminées
aussi les ont croisés dans la lutte
contre le virus
le mot clé la transparence la
transparence libère la population d'une
peur diffuse les coréens ont le droit
d'être informés des dernières évolutions
épidémique et des réponses qui seront
apportées en ce qui concerne le dernier
étape à quels traitements comme la
france tout va s'en remettre
les mesures mises en place par les
différents gouvernements nous pour vous
quatre similaire
la différence majeure en corée et son
système de gestion des patients
particulièrement ceux présentant des
symptômes légers afin de prévenir la
propagation du virus
ils sont provisoirement isoler et dont
les établissements non hospitaliers
appelés centres de traitement et suivi
médicalement ce sommet le président
c'est dans cette crise rien n'aurait été
possible sans la coopération active et
volontaire des citoyens tout comme le
gouvernement français le gouvernement
coréen a lancé une stratégie pour
renforcer l'adhésion et l'engagement de
la population
cette stratégie a encouragé la
distanciation physique ainsi que la
suspension des voyages inutiles et de
certaines activités sociales les
citoyens coréens ont répondu de manière
positive à la compagnie sur les gestes
barrières dont deux portent des masques
j'entends souvent certains mentionné que
les coréens sont culturellement familier
avec le port du masque
or les coréens ont aussi trouve le port
du masque est au fond
et inconfortable cependant grâce à
l'expérience des précédentes j'ai plus
d'amis et les conseils civile deux
experts les coréens dans leur grande
majorité ont accepté le port du masque
ils ont surtout simplement conscience de
l'importance de se protéger les uns les
autres dans la ville côtière de busan à
presque 7 millions de personnes se sont
rendues sur la place pendant ses
vacances
cela n'a pas causé de nouveaux foyers de
propagation
les airs ont amené par la marie du
puissant pour la surveillance du respect
des gestes variées elles semblent avoir
été efficaces et particulièrement sur le
port du masque sur la progression du
cannabis constitue une crise non
seulement sanitaire mais aussi
économiques
le gouvernement coréen comme d'autres a
lancé un programme budgétaire pour
minimiser les conséquences négatives sur
l'économie le gouvernement a aussi
injecté presque 200 milliards d'euros
dans l'économie nationale puis à 3
budget rectificatif est différente
moo-hyun aide financière la pandémie ne
connaît pas de frontières c'est pourquoi
l'ensemble de la communauté
internationale doit coopérer à cet égard
le leadership de la france dans le
combat contre la crise sanitaire
mondiale dans un cadre multilatéral et
reja pc de notre côté et on à la
présidence d'un groupe de l'amitié pour
la sécurité sanitaire mondiale à l'oni l
oms et à l'unesco la corée faire des
efforts pour promouvoir la coopération
internationale
à l'arrière la corée et l'organisation
internationale de normalisation
travaillent ensemble sur la
standardisation des mesures prises par
le gouvernement coréen et donc nos tests
mobiles et drive through et workflow les
centres de traitement l'autodiagnostic
s'il smartphones et les applications
d'auto isolement il faut finir à
l'échelle bilatérale
un autre pays
repères étroitement après l'échangé
téléphonique ont fait le président une
gêne le président emmanuel macron des
projets variés sont encore y compris le
projet de développement d'un traitement
par l'instit parterre pourrais je vous
remercie de votre attention
merci beaucoup monsieur l'ambassadeur je
vais passer maintenant la parole à
philippe lefort ambassadeur de france en
république de corée
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs
merci de l'honneur que vous nous faites
de l'attention que vous portez à
l'expérience coréenne bienvenue si j'ose
dire à l'ambassade de corée
virtuellement
j'espère bientôt physiquement jong-un
mon collègue a dit l'essentiel ce
qu'étaient les grands traits
l'expérience coréenne
je me contente et si vous le permettez
de trois réflexions qui à mon sens
explique le succès coréen dans la lutte
contre la pandémie puisque le pays comme
jean hamon a dit nash a été confiné que
les frontières sont restées ouvertes
mais contrôlé et construit de façon très
sérieuse très près faire et que par
conséquent l'impact de la pandémie sur
la croissance a été limitée par rapport
à celle d'autres économies majeures avec
des estimations qui varie selon les
instituts et qui vont de une perte de 0
point 0 5% de pib à 2 % en cas de
démarrage d'une nouvelle phase
alors les atouts de la corée dans cette
dans cette épreuve était mon avis les
suivants le premier c'est certainement
une conscience plus aiguë partout
ailleurs dans le monde de la présence
est à proximité du danger l'accord est
un pays voisin de la chine la chine est
à l'origine pour des raisons
géographiques et démographiques souvent
un certain nombre de crises sanitaires
donc il ya une conscience accrue du
risque sanitaire au sein de la
population coréenne qui a été
de surcroît particulièrement stimulé par
le précédent de la crise du maire ce le
maire ce que vous le savez est une forme
de coronavirus passant par le chameau en
l'occurrence et qu'ils étaient
originaires du moyen-orient
ça a été une crise douloureuse pour les
coréens en 2015 dont ils ont tiré qu'ils
ont pas forcément d'ailleurs très bien
j'avais à l'époque le gouvernement a
invité les ministres à sion avait été
fort critiquée mais dont ils ont tiré
des enseignements très opérationnelle
enfin comme jean lundi la culture du
masque lié au fait que j'ai activement
les gens ont l'habitude de se protéger
avec parce que faciale celui-ci beaucoup
utilisé pendant les périodes de pics de
pollution aux micro-particules et que au
fond bon je répondrai pas aujourd'hui à
la question que tout le monde se pose
sur les faits du masque sur la pandémie
mais en tout cas ce que leur cas
souligner c'est que le masque un effet
visuel très impressionnant qui est une
forte incitation à la distanciation
sociale alors l'autre atout c'est
l'existence
après antérieures là aussi longue on l'a
dit d'une véritable structure d'état
majeur prépositionnés et qui a été
activé et qui monte en puissance au
moment de la crise avec un plan d'
escalade préétabli à cette occasion
alors d'une façon générale la gestion de
crise ça se passe toujours à peu près de
la même façon et le modèle est
foncièrement militaire ça repose un sur
renseignements 2 sur l'analyse 3 le
commandement 4 sur l'échelle d'exécution
et le cas ces décès dont je vais vous
montrer j'ai une petite infographie
complément de l'intervention je vous en
montrer les structures c'est une
organisation effectivement qui est
établi à l'occasion d'un christ d'une
herse et qui répondent à ces impératifs
sur l'information
ça a été véritablement je crois date ou
de la corée spécifique dans la gestion
de cette crise puisque de l'expérience
du maire est venu effectivement la
certitude qu'il fallait
ferait rapidement disposer des données
permettant de remonter l'échelle de
contamination et ainsi contrôler les
agrégats alors selon on a une vision un
peu excessivement technologique de la
corée en réalité les technologies qui
ont été mises en oeuvre sont tout à fait
ordinaire est disponible c'est comme l'a
dit jean mounet encore une fois
l'agrégation des données de bornage de
téléphonie mobile
c'est pas très précis envie de ça permet
effectivement de déterminer chaque
cellule permet de déterminer un espace
d'environ un euro battant un carré
d'environ 50 mètres à la campagne où les
les
les antennes sont plus rares on est
plutôt de l'ordre de 200 300 mètres mais
ceux ci y croiser effectivement avec les
données tenait encore et on fait
beaucoup avec des cartes de crédit et de
débit et même les plus petits
commerçants acceptent ce moyen de
paiement qui l'as bien entendu des
traces de géolocalisation et enfin le
croisement ddd donné deux issues des
caméras de vidéo protection qui elles
aussi sont présentes à peu près dans
tous les espaces le tout dès le départ
étant échangées avec les opérateurs
parfois d'e-mails et tableaux excel vaut
rien de bien exceptionnel
à partir du moment où le dispositif de
crise est monté en puissance qu'on a
fait appel d'une part à une
industrialisation des échanges de
données avec les opérateurs d'autres
bars à l'utilisation de manière plus
moderne et les coréens sont allés
chercher ce qu'on appelle un système
d'information géographique tirés de
leurs travaux sur la ville intelligente
et qui permet effectivement la
représentation des données sur une carte
l'europe le traçage également des vignes
corporels permettant effectivement de
voir comment se développe un phénomène
du type épidémique donc au départ rien
de miraculeux
c'est pas sur lequel je connais insisté
ni dans les moyens technologiques mis en
oeuvre ni dans les effectifs
là aussi c'est quelque chose qui est
qui n'a pas toujours forcément été bien
compris en france puisque je crois qu'à
un moment donné le chiffre à circuler
deux adjectifs de 20000 personnes
impliquées dans les enquêtes
épidémiologiques véritables chiffres et
nous l'avons vérifié les banques auprès
du bien cédé 6 étaient 4 130 300 à
l'état major et le reste dans les
collectivités territoriales au contact
avec les centres de dépistage donc
véritablement c'est c'est une
organisation qui a prouvé son efficacité
plus qu'une accumulation de moyens comme
jean moulin hiver encore une fois tout
ceci s'est fait conformément à une
législation très protectrice des données
en réalité pratiquement équivalentes à 5
du rgp d s'agissant des législations
européennes et sur le contrôle de la
commission de protection des droits de
l'homme qui en corée est une
organisation qui placés en dehors des
pouvoirs publics ne relève ni du
législatif et exécutif d'eads judiciaire
mais qui est appelé à se saisir va
s'autosaisir de questions impliquant
notamment des questions de protection
des données personnelles
bon bien vu effectivement quelques
petits incidents en la matière puisque
en dehors effectivement des l'agrégation
des données autorisé par la loi contre
les par la loi l'un des coréens ont
aussi une politique de communication en
insistant en cas d'incertitudes à
signaler les cas anonymisées en envoyant
des messages du type sms
là aussi au niveau de la couche
opérateurs sur les téléphones mobiles et
au départ c'était la responsabilité des
collectivités territoriales placé sous
l'autorité du cacd c est bien les
données étaient un peu un peu trop
riches en quelque sorte à dans quelques
cas où effectivement on pouvait assez
facilement des anisés un cas mentionnés
par cette fois là et on a effectivement
eu des cas de personnes qui sont trouvés
identifiés dans des lieux plus comptable
voulant d'edimbourg venables même pas
avec la bonne personne donc le
le la commission des droits de l'homme
s'est saisi d'affaires aux alentours de
la mi mars
et effectivement à donner des consignes
kcdc qui les a récupérés culte et à
l'ensemble de la chaîne d'exécution pour
dégrader la qualité des données sur sur
les cas enfin les questions de
commandement était aussi prise de façon
tout à fait tout à fait sérieuse avec un
système d' escalade avec un maximum de
niveau iv qui implique effectivement là
la prise de direction de l'ensemble du
dispositif par le premier ministre avait
effectivement une réunion tous les
matins à 8h des dieux autour du premier
ministre des membres du cabinet
impliqués dans la lutte contre
l'épidémie biologie donc le système un
système de commandement un système de
renseignement d'analysé commandement
clair ajouté à une chaîne de
commandement elle aussi à une chaîne
d'exécution prédéfinis qui a bien
fonctionné
fondée essentiellement sur les
dispensaires gérés par les collectivités
territoriales haut niveau dans des
grandes villes des mairies
d'arrondissement haut niveau en gros des
cantons en dehors des zones urbaines et
qui sont qui ont été placés en cas de l'
escalade de la réponse à la crise
sous l'autorité du gouvernement et plus
précisément du gacd c'est ce système
d'ailleurs a permis avec un numéro de
téléphone unique le 13 39 de séparer la
chaîne de test et de prise en charge des
des malades ou des personnes suspectées
de porter le virus du reste des
dispositifs d'urgence médicale avait
quitté en invitant effectivement des
effets de saturation soit de la chaîne
de traitement dieu des questions liées
aux côtés d'autres coronavirus soit tu
restes de l'urgence médicale
donc encore une fois à ce dispositif est
directement issues d'expériences du
maire sans 2015 et approuvé
effectivement son efficacité au cours de
la crise et alors l'autre à la troisième
raison c'est la chance ça existe aussi
c'est important
l'un des avantages de la corée par
rapport à d'autres pays dont le nôtre
c'est que le pays n'a pas de frontière
terrestre la tfz n'est pas une frontière
et donc c'est tout naturellement
beaucoup plus face et de contrôler des
frontières aériennes ou maritimes
les coréens ont aussi eu la chance
d'avoir un seul gros agrégats en février
dans la ville de tel-jeunes au milieu
des pays liés effectivement aux
activités de l'église évangélique
hutchinson qui est donc le cas a été à
la fois suffisamment important 25000
personnes touchées pour mobiliser
fortement l'ensemble c'est plus
collectif publics et l'opinion tout en
restant en fin de compte
circonscrit et permettant en quelque
sorte de deux d'éviter un diffusion
incontrôlée du de l'épidémie en fin de
compte du corps et à traiter la pandémie
de la même façon en train d un dancing
forum d'hier on peut pas nous les
attaques informatiques reste on veut pas
éviter les départs de feu mais il faut
éviter que ceux ci se transforme en
incendie c'est ce qu'ils sont parvenus à
faire jusqu'à présent
une petite nuance près qui est
effectivement là les dernières semaines
ou après le 15 août et il ya eu un petit
rebond de décontamination avec une
situation qu'un peu inquiéter nos amis
coréens qui fait qu'ils n'étaient pas
qu'ils arrivaient pas qu'ils n'arrivent
pas encore très bien à retracer les
chefs de contamination sur daniel
épisode est donc ça a conduit à une
élévation de nouveaux dieux du système
d'alerté et de distanciation sociale qui
a conduit notamment et c'est le
dispositif le plus le plus handicapant
l'heure actuelle à la fermeture
temporaire des écoles jusqu'à nouvel
ordre
voilà je termine effectivement en
appelant peut-être votre attention sur
les activités de la corée en matière de
recherche médicale et biomédicale bon la
corée a fait
fait face à va la situation égard comme
partout ailleurs dans le monde
un effet de fatigue parfois d'épuisement
notamment des personnels médicaux et
tout le monde considère ici
effectivement qu'il faut trouver une
solution pérenne à travers 25 thérapie
les choses avancent moins vite
naturellement que je pourrait l'espérer
moi parce que plus tôt on aura une
thérapie - va mieux on sortira de la
crise mais personne à l'heure actuelle
ne peut faire l'impasse sur la
mythologie
il ya plusieurs pistes très très
significative qui ils sont en cours
d'étude
encore et encore et à travers également
la coopération internationale sachant qu
effectivement encore et il ya en gros
plus de ces cliniques qu'il ya de
patients à l'heure actuelle donc c'est
ça se passe effectivement en coopération
avec un certain nombre d'autres d'autres
partenaires mondiaux dans la france il
ya un certain nombre de encore une fois
de pistes qui sont suivis dans tous les
domaines qu'il s'agisse des médicaments
génériques des antilles d d d anticorps
du traitement par placements ou du
vaccin et j'espère effectivement que
dans l'ue les semaines les mois qui
viennent nous ayons de bonnes nouvelles
quelques éléments alors si vous le
permettez d'infographie illustre
rapidement tout ça vous sera distribué
bien entendu ça c'est la chronologie
effectivement des des grandes dates dans
la lutte contre la famine et encore et
vous voyez qu effectivement le niveau
d'alerté 1 a été très rapidement activé
dès janvier et là on reconnaît
effectivement le cpe de sentiments de
proximité aux nouveaux risques chinois
premier cas déclaré en corée l'une
terrain des avantages comparatifs et la
corée c'est qu'elle est très rapidement
à sa disposition
les éléments sur le code génétique du
virus qui lui a permis effectivement
développés de mobiliser très rapidement
sans industrie médicaux pharmaceutiques
pour développer des tests le 18 février
celle explose
dieu de l'agrégat de dégoût avec le
patient 31 l'église shinji petit la mise
en place effectivement de très rapides
en fin de compte de dispositifs de
traçage efficace laprade pratiquement là
la disparition au mois de juin du nombre
de cartes plusieurs jours sans aucun cas
et le retour de retour à partir du 15
août qui conduit temporairement à une à
une
un resserrement des dispositifs en
matière de distanciation sociale voilà
alors les statistiques donc nous vous
les a données en gros on est sur un
facteur de judicial ordre de grandeur du
dixième de ce que nous avons connu en
france et dans d'autres pays européens
vous voyez ici un petit une petite étude
quotidienne qui est fait par nous et
plasticien d'ambassades et quitte à
votre disposition et qui montrent
effectivement le pic en février est la
retombée très rapide a effectivement du
nombre de cas et le retour temporaire
partir de 15h jusqu'à maintenant on
revoit de nouveau là la cour pc après
les dispositions pour une prise très
récemment les secrets de la méthode
coréenne encore une fois c'est sur le
fait que tout ne repose pas sur les
technologistes pas prêt la corée est une
démocratie
l'utilisation des données et contrôlée
il ya beaucoup plus d'acceptation
sociale de l'utilisation des données
personnelles par le gouvernement ça
plombe moon l'a dit et je crois que
c'est un élément important dans le
succès aussi c'est que cette mise à
disposition cette utilisation des
données par 2k cdc des données
personnelles notamment téléphonie mobile
correspondent à une demande sociale
forte qui s'était exprimée notamment à
l'occasion de la crise du maire voici
les quatre niveaux d'alerté pidoux
biologique sécurité mises en oeuvre
alerte bleue alerte jaune alerte orange
alerte rouge
on est passé en fait directement février
du niveau 2 au niveau 4 avec le pilotage
de la crise en direct par le premier
ministre et l' élargissement des
compétences de l'autorité centrale du
gouvernement sur notamment les
dispositifs locaux gérés par les
collectivités territoriales
voici également le plan de distanciation
sociale
alors on est à l'heure actuelle au
niveau 2.5 après être retombé au niveau
2 là aussi c'est via cette à cet épisode
de rebond les structures de l'état major
de crise le cas ces décès dont le modèle
et je crois vraiment militaire ça
pourrait tout à fait se comparer à un
modèle de d'état major gilles de tiko
temps les technologies employées comme
vous le voyez pas de miracle les délais
les données disponibles de localisation
à une géolocalisation chez les
opérateurs
et effectivement des applications à
destination des personnes confinées et
des personnes en excuser moi des
personnes en quarantaine et des
personnes positives et qu'elle l'a sont
beaucoup plus beaucoup plus strictes en
matière de contrôle de développement de
ces de ces personnes voilà en substance
je crois que j'ai dû dépasser les 10
minutes qui laissait un parti les les
les éléments principaux nous avons
analysé côté du côté de notre ambassade
je crois que derrière effectivement
cette crise nous voyons aussi comme l'a
dit jean moulin renforcement nécessaire
indispensable de la coopération
internationale et notamment de la
relation franco coréenne déjà dans ce
pays affinités franchement à la
démocratie et au multilatéralisme
du point de vue de la coopération
scientifique extrêmement forte notamment
avait avec avec le réseau pasteur dans
le domaine de la sorte et de la
coopération industrielle et donc le
souhait nous avons
avec le gouvernement correa de rebondir
sur cette crise
pour contribuer à construire le monde le
vide dans le cadre d'une gouvernance
mondiale rationnelle démocratique et
partenariats industriels
merci de votre attention merci merci
monsieur l'ambassadeur vous avez
effectivement défendu de passer le temps
mais c'était intéressant important
merci en tout cas de ses participations
merci également de solesmes sonneurs
choi je vais passer la parole au
rapporteur qui vont se permettre de vous
pc des questions précises je commence
par bernard jomier aujourd'hui merci
monsieur président merci beaucoup
messieurs les ambassadeurs pour votre
exposé qui qui pour nous est très utile
parce que comme l'a dit l'ambassadeur le
fort en conclusion nous sommes une
communauté internationale et comprendre
comment les autres pays qui plus est
avec un système démocratique ont fait
face à la pandémie est pour nous de
toute façon très instructif notamment vu
des résultats vous avez obtenu alors
j'aimerais quelques précisions la
première monsieur en bazar donc nous
avait expliqué que c'est le cas ces
décès étaient une autorité indépendante
un centre de contrôle et de prévention
des maladies donc une autorité de santé
publique indépendante si j'ai bien
compris et donc qui était chargé de
piloter la réponse à une épidémie donc
en l'occurrence et j'aurais voulu que
parce que l'ambassadeur le fort après
nous a expliqué décrit un système piloté
par le premier ministre très vertical
d'ailleurs très centralisé avec une si
on a bien compris une grande efficacité
descendante et une application sur
l'ensemble du territoire de façon
déconcentrés des deux de la stratégie
portée nationalement donc qu'elle est
comment s'articule cette autorité
indépendante le cas cdc avec les
autorités politiques
est ce que le ministère de la santé
est en première ligne oui ou non comment
ce lien entre l'autorité indépendante et
le pouvoir politique se est établi et
porter vis-à-vis des citoyens parce que
unes des questions auxquelles nous
faisons face c'est la qualité est là
le respect de la parole publique pour
nos concitoyens
la deuxième question je voudrais vous
poser c'est la place des tests du
dépistage dans votre stratégie
vous nous avez dit que vous étiez arrivé
un mois après le début de l'épidémie
serge eux pendant la phase la plus
active à 40 mille tests par jour
j'aurais voulu savoir
actuellement est ce que vous êtes
toujours au même niveau ce qui est
relativement en fait pas important donc
est-ce que vous êtes toujours au même
niveau est ce que vous faites plus de
test - le test
quelle est votre stratégie de dépistage
dans et sa part pour contenir l'épidémie
voilà je m'en tiendrai là merci
mais benneteau
ici alors je vais d'abord commencez à
vous parler de la casse et des ses lacs
ac dc a vu le jour en 2004 et donc qui
vu le jour après la pandémie dussart ce
et depuis 2015 donc elle a connu des
pouvoirs beaucoup plus élargie et elle
est en fait affiliée au ministère de la
santé et des affaires sociales coréenne
mais c'est un organisme qui est très
spécialisé professionnelle et qui a
vraiment des experts au sein de cette
organisation et à cause de cette
pandémie d'épidémie d'une couronne virus
cette semaine le canal du rove et le
canada sur le petit compteur ses marques
et la traduction et ensuite vous régler
le volume par les boutons de gauche en
augmentant en diminuant les petits
boutons grille de gauche horizontaux
c'est bon tout le monde est branché
merci vous pouvez reprendre mais aussi
ok c'est bon donc je vais vous parler de
l'acca cdc la cassa cdc comme vous venez
de le dire est affiliée au ministère de
la santé des affaires sociales coréenne
en 2004 à cause de l'épidémie du
sarcelles a donc été créé à ce moment là
et depuis le maire sans 2015 ses
pouvoirs ont été accrus ce qui est très
important aujourd'hui c'est que elle est
affiliée bien sûr au ministère de la
santé mais à cause de son expertise en
termes d'organisation elle est tout à
fait indépendante et même le ministère
des affaires étrangères par exemple pour
la fermeture des frontières pour ce
sujet là en fait elle tient vraiment
content en fait de l'avis de la casse et
décédant qu'elle est vraiment
indépendante et donc le 10 décembre donc
cette semaine le cac cdc va être encore
plus devenir plus important son
organisation son budget tout va être
accrue et ce qui est important jusqu'ici
c'est que pour l'instant c'était un peu
une sorte de bras droit en fait du
gouvernement local est donc maintenant
elle va commencer à
non seulement aider le gouvernement
central mais le gouvernement local et
concernant les tests comme je vous
disais la corée a pu réussir donc la
production à lutter contre l'épidémie
s'est d'abord d'anticipation qui a fait
la différence au début en fait avant
même début janvier avant même qu'il y
ait le premier cas confirmé de kovy 19
le milieu biotechnologique a commencé à
développer un test de dépistage
donc c'est pour ça qu'on a on a pu être
les premiers à développer les tests de
dépistage et dès le début en fait on
avait une approche maximaliste si je
puis dire c'est à dire que à l'époque on
devait avoir parce que tu as beaucoup de
pays devait avoir une ordonnance pour y
réaliser les tests mais encore et à
partir du moment où on est présenté des
symptômes du code vide
mais même si le médecin disait qu'il n'y
avait pas besoin mais que soi même on
pensait qu'il qu'on avait des risques de
de porter le viry de virus on pouvait
être testés évidemment les personnes qui
venaient de l'étranger où nivea trop
tester donc en gros on peut dire que
toutes les personnes qui voulaient être
testés pouvait être testé ce qui est
important c'est aussi le fait d'être
asymptomatiques
ça c'était un problème donc il se
pouvait que certaines personnes
asymptomatiques pouvait contaminer
d'autres personnes sans le savoir donc
ce qui est important c'est eux c'était
de tout de suite les identifier de les
tester et de les isoler donc ça c'était
à mesure qu'on avait mis en place très
rapidement
et après le 5 février il y avait environ
20000 à 40000 personnes qu'on pouvait
tester par jour donc aujourd'hui les
chiffres voile avant le 20 mille
quarante mille mais je dirais que notre
capacité maximale est de 70 mille tests
par jour merci m rapporte aujourd'hui
sylvie vermeillet poser ses questions
merci monsieur le président merci
messieurs les ambassadeurs
j'aurai trois questions tout d'abord
chez l'ambassadeur de la république de
corée en france qu'en est-il sur votre
nom votre autonomie en matière de
production d'équipements de protection
individuelle est ce que c'est à la suite
des crises précédentes que vous avez
développé votre capacité de production
comment est ce que vous vous êtes adapté
est ce que vous étiez prêts en fait dès
les alertes de début d'année
est ce que vous étiez prêts à ce niveau
là est ce que vous aviez les équipements
nécessaires pour faire face à la crise
et puis ma deuxième question concerne
l'activité économique
en fait votre pays n'a jamais été
confinés les frontières sont restées
ouvertes
donc je comprend l'activité économique a
continué et néanmoins votre gouvernement
injecte 2 100 milliards dans l'économie
quelles sont les activités qui ont été
touchés et qu'ils justifient que le
gouvernement injecte de 100 milliards et
puis j'aurai une troisième question pour
monsieur l'ambassadeur le fort est-ce
que vous pouvez nous nous en dire un peu
plus sur l'état de la recherche
concernant l'institut pasteur en cours
et merci merci monsieur l'ambassadeur
monsieur le fort je vous passe la parole
pour répondre à la question de sylvie
vermeillet je redonnerai la parole
ensuite monsieur l'ambassadeur de corée
en france monsieur le fort merci
monsieur le président merci madame la
sénatrice
voilà comme s'il s'agit de recherche
clinique en cours je ne vous répondrai
que de manière générale parce que nous
sommes ça sera un certain une certaine
impasse impératif de discrétion
s'agissant notamment de l'implication de
gouvernement thiers l'institut pasteur
de corée est effectivement un des
centres du dispositif de recherche
coréen l'organisation qu'au real bien
sûr qu'ils s'insèrent dans le réseau
pasteur et qui associe deux
caractéristiques d'associer d'une part
les accès à toutes les bibliothèques
d'agents infectieux inhérentes au réseau
pasteur avec un laboratoire de niveau 3
donc à très haut niveau de sécurité est
également des investissements très
importants qui ont été accomplis dans le
domaine de l'imagerie biologique donc
depuis le départ de la crise ils se sont
beaucoup investis dans l'analyse in
vitro de l'activité d'environ 150
molécules génériquées nom ou non et ils
ont réussi à en sélectionner 3 dont la
capacité est effectivement très très
prometteuse
donc il s'agit par dagg d'un
anticoagulant d'un anti parasitaire et
d'un anti inflammatoire
à l'heure actuelle des recherches ont
été engagées en corée sur
le premier médicament qui était un
générique employé depuis une vingtaine
40 ans en corée au japon dont le
l'historique de sécurité et est
indéniable et c'est une des pistes
véritable prometteuses sur lesquels la
corée et d'autres pays travaillent à
l'heure actuelle il ya 1 heure actuelle
aussi des recherches très actives qui se
font de la part de plusieurs entreprises
pharmaceutiques coréenne notamment sur
des médicaments à base d'anticorps
destinés à empêcher de la pénétration du
virus à travers ce qu'on appelle alors
la protéine spy s qui sont elles mêmes
dérives et de recherches qui avaient été
faites par parlait même pas des mêmes
centres sur le maire ce et sûre sur les
mollahs en partie il ya également des
recherches très actives qui se font sur
les l'utilisation du plasma sanguin un
des personnes guéries et il ya déjà des
pistes qui justifie pour certains de ces
entreprises la préparation de capacités
industrielles de production donc le
coeur on est je crois qu'on est quand
même pas très loin d'une solution
thérapeutique
on garde naturellement de la contrainte
que constitue la nécessité de respecter
tous les stades nécessaires en matière
de méthodologie
voilà ce qui forcément un peu frustrant
parce que on est naturellement aller
beaucoup plus vite dans la matière voilà
même si tu pourras pour attirer votre
attention sur le fait que la corée est
le pays au monde désormais où la
recherche publique par habitant il a plu
à nu devant israël
c'est cette précision importante
monsieur jean basset troy bell que en
tripotant guy continent concernant les
équipements de protection individuelle
alors d'abord je vais parler des masques
le 20 janvier dès qu'on a eu le premier
cas confirmé
et quand on avait en tout après donc
quatre personnes au total cumulé le 18
déjà le gouvernement a déclaré les
gestes barrières les mesures sa terre
sanitaires et a demandé un recommandé à
toute la population de porter des
masques surtout déjà à l'intérieur est
également tous les visiteurs
d'établissement à haut risque ce qui est
important c'est que le gouvernement le
milieu médical le milieu académique tout
le monde vraiment recommandé le port du
masque
donc pendant les sept derniers mois
encore et personne n'a dérogé à la règle
tout le monde il y avait vraiment un
consensus sur le port du masque pendant
environ un mois
il est vrai qu'en corée deux avions eu
une petite période d'instabilité où on
n'arrivait pas faux curé de mesk car on
avait environ 25 millions de masques et
puis après on avait 30 millions de
masques et qu'on arrivait à produire et
puis on a lu à brouiller le 40 à 60
millions
donc en fait je veux dire que l'offre
était supérieure à la demande donc on
n'avait pas vraiment de problème
d'approvisionnement
et puis quand le corona virus on a eu un
deuxième rebond on a eu une sorte de
d'achat de panique
donc les gens l'achat de panique
consiste voilà pas les gens étaient très
fan hic est donc tout le monde ce sont
les gens se sont rués sur les masques
donc il y avait des problèmes
d'approvisionnement donc pour lutter
contre ça le gouvernement a pris deux
mesures
c'était d'abord d'utiliser les
technologies donc toutes les pharmacies
de la corée était dans une partagé dans
une base de données en fait chaque
habitant coréen pouvait se procurer un
deux ou trois masques dans une pharmacie
donc si par exemple moi j'allais dans
une pharmacie à mais que je voulais à
aller me procurer des basques dans une
pharmacie mais c'était impossible en
fait parce que justement on avait une
base de données qui partageait qui évite
est en fait une personne aille acheter
d'autres masques alors qu'on était en
pénurie de masques
donc elle est vraiment une transparence
et donc après voilà cet achat le
mouvement d'achat de panique a cessé
puisque les masques étaient rationnés
et puis en fait il y avait aussi une
incitation à la production des masques
en termes de taxes par exemple en termes
de dead au recrutement aussi pour les
heures supplémentaires il y avait eu des
aides et subventions
donc à partir de fin février la pénurie
de masques avait commencé mais en tout
cas prêts en mois de mars on avait plus
du tout eu ce problème qui a été réglé
et au mois de juillet on n'a plus du
tout ce rationnement donc n'importe qui
pouvait se procurer le nombre de masques
qu'ils voulaient au prix du marché
danielo est en tout cas par semaine au
début février il y a dix millions de
masques qui était produit et fin août on
avait là par semaine on a
et actuellement on arrive à produire 273
millions de la sq par semaine sinon en
termes de vêtements de produits de
traitement de protection
on avait déjà des stocks de réserve donc
on n'avait pas vraiment de problème
d'approvisionnement
et concernant les appareils médicaux
avec le coronavirus est également bon la
france aussi car je regardais les
journaux le plus important effectivement
c'est vraiment les appareils médicaux
centrale et on est aussi un très
dépendants de l'étranger comme la france
donc c'est pour ça que le gouvernement a
décidé pour douze appareils médicaux
importants de de faire des subventions
pour inciter à ce que ces appareils
médicaux soient produits localement
encore et donc la corée a bien sûr les
détecte lino technologie mais parfois il
ya certains appareils qui sont beaucoup
plus achetés à l'étranger
donc nous allons continuer à développer
ses technologies
alors il ya par exemple les expos les
thérapies dorée de remplacement rénale
continuent tous le pays les équipements
pcr où nous avons encore une
technologique qui restent encore à être
plus développée et nous sommes
actuellement également en train de
l'urban cruiser 200 euros euros seront
subventionnés alors il ya beaucoup de
domaines par exemple le tourisme les
restaurants beaucoup d'autres domaines
qui ont besoin de ce plan de relance et
on parle de new deal vert en corée à
cause du changement climatique on va
essayer de d'apporter vraiment une aide
et un soutien aux industries vertes
ce plan de relance était aussi vraiment
dédié aux à chaque foyer
donc chaque foyer a également obtenu une
aide financière pour tous les documents
un peu plus précis bien sûr nous vous
les environs ils sont à votre
disposition
merci monsieur le président et je
remercie bien évidemment les
ambassadeurs pour la qualité de leur
communication qui pour nous sera très
instructive dans l'élaboration du
rapport que nous devons faire
j'avais une question à monsieur
l'ambassadeur de corée
vous nous avez dit que au départ les
patients
étaient isolés dans des centres 90 80
des établissements hospitaliers centres
traitement et suivi médicalement
ma question est combien dure l isolement
et comment se faisait la sortie de ces
établissements est ce que c'était par le
biais d'un nouveau test sur les tests
vous l'avais un peu évoquée lorsque vous
a parlé t&d technique pcr à la réponse à
sylvie vermeillet mais est-ce que
puisque vous avez une capacité de tests
importante est ce que les tests étaient
été fabriquée en corée et l'autre
l'autre question concerne est concerné
monsieur l'ambassadeur vous avez évoqué
des essais cliniques
vous savez qu'il ya des débats en france
sur traitement par hydroxy chloroquine
ya eu également des essais sur leur md
et vire quels sont les essais cliniques
ont été ont été pratiqués encadrés et
quelle est la place justement des
toxiques lankin ou la non place de et
roxy clarkin dans votre pays sûr merci
oui monsieur le fort vous vous commencez
s'il vous plaît monsieur l'ambassadeur
je comprends que c'est un sujet un peu
sensible les en première intention
alors d'abord il faut il faut savoir que
encore et je parle contrôle de
l'ambassadeur tchèque les les
la réponse médicale a été très largement
décentralisé auprès des médecins et
surtout des institutions hospitalières
qui rédige traditionnellement dé des
recommandations de thérapie donc il ya
pu y avoir effectivement un certain
nombre de pistes qui ont été suivis au
départ différentes selon les régions et
selon les hôpitaux et dans l'ensemble la
première réponse a été effectivement
d'essayer d'utiliser la combinaison qui
vira le kaletra ainsi que leur mdc lire
leur mdc vire a été autorisé sa sont
très très ponctuel mais déclenche pas
beaucoup d'enthousiasmé en corée 1 a
connaissance il n'y a pas d' essai
clinique concernant l'horaire de ses
filles le caennais tarder
et maintenant je prends à peu près
complètement abandonné en revanche le
leader cycle heureux qui n'a été
prescrite par beaucoup de médecins en
corée dans un second temps et un prêt de
l'étude chinoise de du mois tu enfin
tout cela figure dans les réponses
écrites aux questionnaires vous avez
bien voulu me payer
voilà cent sans véritable et je crois
qu'effectivement il ya un des essais
cliniques qui est menée en corée qui
penche sur sur les drogues secteur
auxquelles je crois aussi que la
combinaison avec l'azithromycine n'a pas
véritablement été utilisée à ce stade
alors ils gagnent encore une fois hier
il ya beaucoup d'essais cliniques qui
sont menées en ce moment en coopération
avec des pays tiers puisque faute de
ballades eu suffisamment sérieux en
corée il y à des essais qui sont menées
sur certains médicaments génériques dont
ceux qui ont été identifiés par
l'institut pasteur
il ya des essais qui sont menées
également sur les anticorps et il ya des
essais sur le plasma l'ensemble devrait
nous donne et j'espère des pistes
vraiment intéressante sur plusieurs
mètres de thérapie d'enlever semaine et
dans les mois qui viennent en revanche
sur la dimension vaccin là je parle
encore contrôle de l'ambassade us chez
les coréens se sont mis même probables
sont sans véritablement à ce stade nous
produire de résultats
[Musique]
enfin le véritablement de décès à grande
échelle
merci monsieur l'ambassadeur précisément
vous dites que la réponse médicale a été
décentralisée est ce que les médecins
locaux avaient la possibilité de script
prescrire selon leur leurs connaissances
du moment bien sûr elle s'attend
d'exception ont été consentis à cet
égard sur notamment les règles de
remboursement des médicaments qui sont
très encadrés par le système de sécurité
sociale coréenne et qui ont été levées
pour evi pour donner aux médecins le
maximum de marge de meneur dans leur
évaluation thérapeutique
merci monsieur l'ambassadeur
monsieur l'ambassadeur de quoi
aussi cette invitation bonne table à qui
michael tôt pour vous résumer un peu le
système coréen après les tests une fois
que lors qu'un cas est confirmé
donc en fait il y à des patients bien
sûr c'est le médecin qui décide si le
patient a des symptômes graves ou alors
des symptômes légers les patients les
jets sont transférés à l'hôpital dans
les patients graves sont transférés à
l'hôpital et sont soignés et puis pour
les patients léger parce parfois ils
peuvent être asymptomatique ou penser
qu'ils ont juste un rhume
donc au début ils allaient à l'hôpital
mais comme il y avait pour l'hôpital en
fait une charge beaucoup trop lourde
on ne pouvait pas non plus les laisser à
la maison car ils pouvaient propager le
virus
donc ces patients-là léger les guider
vers un centre de traitement qu'on peut
appeler un centre d'isolement en fait
ils allaient dans des résidences qu'ils
savaient pour des séminaires
d'entreprises
donc il y en a environ 140 en corée donc
voilà il était isolé dans ces lieux là
et après les médecins deux fois par jour
aller les voir pour voir comment ils
allaient leur état de santé leur donner
des médicaments et si bien sûr leur état
s'aggraver il aller dans des hôpitaux
c'est donc le fait est donc dans ces
voix là il ya ces centres de traitement
et les hôpitaux
concernant les hôpitaux dès qu'il ya eu
cette épidémie de colleville nous avons
défini 70 hôpitaux dédié aux convives 19
seulement donc vraiment dédié
donc le gouvernement a mis un certain
budget pour que c'est hôpitaux soient
vraiment dédié puis il ya également les
chu les hôpitaux environ une centaine
d'hôpitaux où il y avait un quota où on
pouvait traiter ces patients on a ouvert
des lits supplémentaires concernant les
personnes âgées encore et c'était pareil
les personnes les cas confirmés et les
personnes décédées
il est environ encore et 300 personnes
qui sont décédées en tout et en termes
de proportion
il y à 50% qui sont des octogénaires et
après des septuagénaires bowling de
windows phone et les septuagénaires
représenter cent deux personnes donc 30%
les sexagénaires 40 personnes donc 12,5
pour cent comme monoprix solide donc les
établissements haut risque c'est un peu
comme en fait les ce qu'on appelle les
ehpad en france
le premier cas était en feu le 20
janvier il y avait 30 personnes
soutiennent et donc on le gouvernement a
décidé de limiter les visites dans ces
ehpad et dès qu'une personne qui
travaillait dans ces ehpad est
représenté de certains symptômes on les
isoler elle n'allait plus travaillé et
par exemple les nouveaux résidents
l'acceptance des nouveaux résidents
étaient un peu limités ou retardé afin
de surveiller pour savoir si le suivi
que le suivi de la situation tous les
jours on avait des réunions donc pour
voir l'état pour faire le point sur le
kobe 19 ans merci merci pour ces
précisions
catherine des roches oui une
est-ce que les gens avant de sortir des
centres de traitement il ne sortait que
s'il avait un test négatif tu as une
question et sur les tests sont fabriqués
en corée
belga
comme nous à quito caught in town se
quitter le qui te déteste l'équipe
dépistage était autosuffisant à 100% il
était coréen et on est les premiers au
monde d'ailleurs à faire une production
de masse donc nous avons même exporté
des kits il y a d'ailleurs 149 pays à
qui nous avons exporté ou alors donné
gracieusement comme aide humanitaire à
149 pays alors effectivement oui on peut
on sort des centres de traitement
seulement qu'en tournée testés négatifs
que qui est alors c'est quelque chose
qui a un rapport avec votre question on
dit que la corée a été très strictes en
termes de lutte contre le coc vide alors
effectivement les coréens peuvent se
sentir gêné mais quand une personne par
exemple a dîné avec une personne qui a
qui est un cas confirmé donc c'est un
cas contacts quand ils ont dîné ensemble
après ces personnes là sont testés et
même si ce cas contact est un cas
négatifs alors je ne sais pas après
comment ça se passe pour les autres pays
je pense que rien ne se passe en tout
cas en corée pour ces cas contactez la
qui représente vraiment un risque de
contamination
on leur recommande de s'isoler
même si ces îles ont un test négatif et
la plupart de la population accepte ce
dispositif alors même que la personne et
testées négatives
en fait on recommande cet isolement
parce que il y à une incubation de 14
jours donc même quand on est testé
négatif on ne sait pas si cette personne
peut cette personne peut devenir positif
dans l'espace deux des quatorze jours
donc c'est pour ça qu'on recommande une
14ème et pendant ces 14 jours un
fonctionnaire communique avec sept
personnes à travers une application est
donc si cette personne ne se sent mal
elle peut demander à ce que quelqu'un
vienne la consulter et ses
fonctionnaires voient la demande
il ya une sorte de suivi pour savoir si
pendant ces 14 jours la personne se sent
bien et après les 14 jours la carte sd
attaque attaque à 14h30
merci en complément vous souhaitez
rester sur la 14è nous vous envisager de
réduire ce délai qui me semble-t-il est
plus un isolement qu'une quarantaine
chez vous
la personne est isolée où elle peut
rester en famille donc en quarantaine
comme on le fait en france et est ce que
vous souhaite changer à réduire ce délai
de 14 jours pour ses 14 jours je vais
vous donner un exemple je vous parlais
de deux personnes qui avaient dîné
ensemble disons que la personne a il y a
cinq jours dîner avec une personne qui
est un cas confirmé est en fait ça va
être cinq pistes 14 donc en fait il
reste neuf jours d'isolement pour
l'incubation de 14 jours pour l'instant
le gouvernement coréen n'a pas changé
donc pour l'instant il est pas vraiment
encore question de réduire cette période
de quatorze jeunes de 14 ans donc voilà
on va en tout cas maintenir ses quatorze
jours indice allemand
c'est je vais passer aux questions de
nos commissaires j'en ai six d'inscrits
pour l'instant nous allons les prendre 3
par 3 damien regnard
merci monsieur le président je vais être
aux questions une était déjà longuement
traité sur
la hiérarchisation le cas ces décès donc
je ne reviendrai pas dessus
monsieur l'ambassadeur fait je
souhaiterais que vous nous expliquiez la
procédure pour les voyageurs qu'ils
soient coréen de retour dans leur pays
ou des voyageurs étrangers qui arrivent
sur le territoire coréen
et quand je parle de procédures je parle
de l'arrivée à l'aéroport de mesures qui
pourraient être prises avant le départ
j'ai lu que vous étiez en capacité de
tester tous les étrangers qui arrivent à
l'aéroport est ce que c'est le cas cela
représente à peu près combien de test et
comment vous gérez si vous avez les
informations là-dessus
l'afflux des passagers venant de
l'étranger
nous allons au sein de notre commission
allez nous rendre à roissy charles de
gaulle qui fait preuve d'un grand
amateurisme apparemment et de grandes
lacunes de sécurité et je suis très
intéressé par les procédures qui ont été
mises en place par au service le
gouvernement français a passé un décret
fin juillet exigeant des tests pcr 72
heures avant pour un certain nombre de
pays
donc voila j'aimerais savoir un petit
peu sur cette partie monsieur
l'ambassadeur france j'avais une
question étant sénateur des français
établis hors de france
je suis je souhaiterais avoir rapidement
on va pas pouvoir faire un tour complet
de la situation mais nous avons une
communauté d'environ 4000 4500 français
en corée et dont la situation économique
chambre de commerce financière alliances
françaises instituts français et la
situation sanitaire de nos
ressortissants et les possibilités pour
eux de voyage est de retour en france
voilà sur sur la partie un petit peu
communauté française quels sont les
impacts et le lycée français
l'enveloppent des bourses l'aide sociale
qui était très difficilement négocier
ici pour nos ressortissants à l'étranger
merci merci olivier paccaud merci
monsieur le président messieurs les
ambassadeurs merci beaucoup pour cette
présentation rigoureuse et passionnante
les citoyens et le gouvernement français
sont français ils sont pas sud coréens
et donc on a certainement beaucoup de
choses à apprendre de ce que vous avez
vécu ce que vous avez mis en place
l'anticipation
j'ai bien retenu ce mot l'organisation
sont érigées comme des sciences entre
guillemets chez vous mais si c'est le
cas c'est parce que vous avez et c'est
ce que vous nous avez dit monsieur
l'ambassadeur de corée subi d'autres
épidémies dans le passé vous en avez
tiré les leçons
alors vous avez parlé donc du strass du
h1n1 du h5n1 et du maire objectivement
je connaissais les trois premiers je
connaissais pas le dernier est
l'ambassadeur le fort a insisté sur le
fait que le maire avait provoqué une
sorte d'électrochoc
petite question toute bête quel a été le
bilan du maire ce ma deuxième question
elle concerne les masques vous avez dit
beaucoup de choses à ce sujet et donc
j'avais plusieurs questions mais je vais
la limite et il ya visiblement une
autodiscipline formidable chez vous
il ya des lois une loi consensuelle qui
a été votée concernant justement le port
du masque son irrespect est il possible
enfin de quoi est-il passible d'une
amende
quel est le montant de cette amende on a
eu des chiffres très précis
combien de concitoyens de vos
concitoyens ont-ils éventuellement été
verbalisé pour non port du masque merci
angèle préville
merci merci monsieur le président merci
messieurs les ambassadeurs pour vos
interventions à moi j'avais une question
sur ce que vous aviez évoqué au sujet de
la lutte contre le virus dont le mot clé
est la transparence et vous avez évoqué
pour la vidéosurveillance et et ses
applications donc de suivi d'avoir
consulté des experts des associations et
l'opinion publique et j'aurais voulu
savoir de quelle manière vous aviez
consulter l'opinion publique est ensuite
concernant le la lutte contre cette
pandémie
monsieur l'ambassadeur lefort vous avez
mentionné que on ne peut pas éviter les
départs de feu mais qu' évidemment la
rapidité est ce que d'après l'expérience
que vous avez des précédentes pandémies
effectivement la réaction immédiate est
importante
merci merci je vais demander à monsieur
le fort de répondre en premier le temps
que monsieur choi puis se traduire
monsieur le fort oui merci monsieur le
président merci mesdames et messieurs
sur la communauté française nous sommes
un petit peu plus nombreux en réalité
puisque nous comptons au sein du
consulat
6000 foyers enregistré donc communauté
très active très très engagé dans la
dans le dans les affaires somme
l'un des principaux investisseurs
européens encore hélas vrai dire le
stock d'investissements français en
corée est cinq fois supérieur à celui du
stock des investissements coréens en
france d'ailleurs à ce sujet sur lequel
nous travaillons pour encourager bien
sûr nos amis coréens à consentir les
mêmes investissements dans notre dans
notre notre pays notamment pour
contribuer à son développement
industriel
cette communauté a réagi avec beaucoup
de calme beaucoup de sagesse de
discipline aussi vis-à-vis des consignes
qui était qui était donné à nos parts
par les autorités coréennes nous avons
dû traiter un certain nombre de cas de
personnes non relativement plus fragiles
et précaires notamment ce qu'on appelle
de l'est les jeunes venant sur des visas
du type vacances travail dont le
l'organisation du départ était un sujet
significatif pour pour l'ambassade
nous n'avons nous n'avons pas
véritablement de problème massif de de
situation sociale précaire
à l'heure actuelle mais nous avons prévu
effectivement outre les aides de l'an ii
publics qui sont relativement de test un
dispositif plus tu as liste avec
notamment la chambre de commerce
franco-coréenne qui nous permet de
disposer de fonds dead permettant de
venir au secours des personnes en
situation difficile à l'heure actuelle
les problèmes principaux touche les auto
entrepreneurs notamment toute la toute
toute tous nos compatriotes qui ont
choisi la corée comme base de départ
pour la start up c'est du buzz c'est une
star public très technique très détresse
et vicky et il est très important nous
avons encore de la réserve
nous pouvons encore faire face à aux
difficultés éventuelles qu'il pourrait
se manifester dans l'ensemble encore une
fois peu de problèmes sociaux
manif est important au sein d'une
population orange devrait des
difficultés sur le retour en france et
le retour en corée en provenance de
france du fait de l'existence d'avoirs
d'une 14e cette contrainte importante je
me suis plié comme tout le monde tu
restes à mon retour de france mais
également à des dispositions qui
auraient été prises par la corée
notamment la restauration de
l'obligation de visas de court séjour en
contrepartie de la fermeture de la
frontière de schengen nous avons nous
bons fonds levés l'ensemble des
contraintes pesant sur les voyageurs
coréen en france et dans l'est dans
l'espace schengen étant entendu que nous
considérons l'accord comme un un pays
d'origine sûrs en revanche nous
aimerions effectivement que les coréens
lève l'obligation de visas pour
faciliter les échanges entre nos deux
pays
voilà ce que je peux dire à l'instant
notre short plan sanitaire notre notre
communauté a été peu touché nous avons
eu je crois que ça doit pas dépasser 5
personnes et qui ont été détectés
positive en encore est à la fois des
voyageurs et des résidents dont une
jeune fille qui était hospitalisée
pendant plusieurs semaines avec souvent
des complications mais qu'il sentait
fort heureusement des sorties merci ce
choc
mais benneteau que
alors en 2015 lors de l'épidémie du
maire ce qu'on a eu 38 personnes qui ont
été qui sont décédés 38
bien sûr en tout premier c'était
l'arabie saoudite et la corée a été le
deuxième pays à être le plus touché
la différence de la lutte contre
l'épidémie et à l'époque et aujourd'hui
je dirais que à l'époque on n'était pas
encore prêt et c'est pour ça qu'on a
malheureusement perdu ses 38 personnes
et c'est à cause de cela que le système
s'est amélioré par la suite qu'on a
développée en mieux le système et on a
pu être apte 7 aujourd'hui justement à
être plus prêts à être plus performants
comme monsieur lefort l'a dit tout à
l'heure ils y allaient big data les
nouvelles tech nos logis qui ont aussi
servi et qui n'existait peut-être pas
encore à l'époque donc ils ont beaucoup
étaient utiles concernant votre question
sur l'aéroport mais c'est le fort la
digue également dit tout à l'heure
bobby orr cook donc au delà au poteau
tous les pays qui étaient exempts de
visa pendant 90 jours lorsqu'ils
visitaient la corée
cette mesure a été suspendue
temporairement pour l'instant à partir
de fin mars
deux femmes meurent sans fait 10% des
cas confirmés étaient des cas importés
donc à cause de cela pour éviter une
plus grande contamination quand les
venez les gens venaient pour visiter la
corée ont demandé donc un test négatif
et ça c'est vraiment la première ligne
de défense de notre stratégie il faut
que la personne qui demande le visa
présente un résultat de test négatif et
c'est avec ça que l'on attribue le visa
shopping
la personne a son billet pour la cour et
quand elles arrivent en cours et elle
repasse un test voyante épisode parce
qu'après avoir reçu son visa
pendant le temps jusqu où elle a pris
l'avion et qu'elle arrivait en cours et
pendant tout ce temps là elle peut avoir
eu des contaminés donc elle est testée
et une fois qu'elle est testé à son
arrivée à l'aéroport
le résultat du test arrive dans les 24
heures
on obtient les résultats en 24 heures et
après que ce soit des ressortissants
coréens ou étrangers la même règle
s'applique il n'ya aucune discrimination
les personnes qui sont testées positives
vont à l'hôpital
et même quand elles ne sont testées
positives et qu'elles sont négatifs dès
qu'on vient de l'étranger
elles sont autorisées au lait donc merci
à l'aéroport ils sont testés négatifs
ils doivent être iso de s'auto ils
doivent s'auto isolé et pendant l'auto
isolement ils ne peuvent pas du tout
partager le même espace avec d'autres
personnes ils doivent vraiment être
isolé être complètement à part
c'est pas non plus de mesures strictes à
100% quand par exemple les personnes
viennent pour des funérailles ou quand
il ya vraiment une réunion stratégique
entre la france et la corée ou alors
qu'il y a un deal économique ou qu'à
cause du business en fait à cause des
affaires il ya des échanges ou quelque
chose et un contrat important qui se
conclut là il ya des ex-anpe des
exemptions à l'auto isolement concernant
les masques
oui il y à des amendes si le port du
masque
je dirais que oui c'est environ 70 % en
euros c'est 70 euros d'amendé lorsque la
personne ne porte pas le masque donc il
ya certaines personnes qui ne respectent
pas cette règle mais plus que la règle
je dirais que en corée il ya une sorte
de consensus qui fait que quand on porte
le masque pour se protéger soi même et
qu'on protège aussi les autres dont le
coeur voilà certes de consensus qui fait
qu' on est bas l'amant n'est pas quelque
chose d'important en fait les gens se
disent qu'ils se protègent eux-mêmes et
également les autres donc ce n'est pas
quelque chose qui est vraiment l'amour
n'est pas vraiment un point clé je
dirais et sinon comme je vous disais en
2015 il y a eu la casse et d'essai donc
a eu des pouvoirs accrus et parmi ces
fonctions qui ont été accrus ce qui est
le plus important c'est le traçage le
pouvoir de traçage donc la possibilité
de collecter les données à l'époque les
tables rondes les parlementaires il ya
environ 300 parlementaires en corée et
en corée il n'y a pas de c'est pas eu un
stand by kamerhe liste
donc il y environ 30 qui ont
parlementaires qui ont proposé un
amendement à la loi et donc c'était
effectivement quelque chose de très
important à l'époque parce que tout le
monde disait que ça allait à l'encontre
de la vie privée donc si bien
s'inquiéter si l'on prend comme yann on
a eu beaucoup de discussions avec la
société civile avec l'opinion publique
et en conclusion je vous disais que la
loi avait été passé il y a eu 247 pour 0
contre et deux abstentions
donc c'est vraiment une majorité
écrasante avec une majorité écrasante
que la loi était passé et à l'époque
donc l'opposition et le parti au pouvoir
commencer aussi un peu changé de camp
mais c'est pour ça que je vous dis qu'en
fait pour cette loi-là la population
coréenne a vraiment ils sont il ya
vraiment un consensus auprès de cette
loi est le cas cdc est vraiment expert
dans son domaine
merci donc bien une consultation
publique etc pour l'acceptation des
mesures pour répondre à la question de
madame préville et puis il ya également
si certaines personnes qui ont relevé ce
problème là donc on a vraiment discuter
avec eux pour essayer de trouver
un consensus est pour apaiser les
peuples mais encore et vous savez il ya
52 millions de citoyens donc dans ces 52
millions bien sûr il ya des personnes
qui sont contre des personnes qui sont
réticents à ces mesures là mais je
dirais qu'il ya vraiment une majorité
écrasante sur ces mesures sanitaires
tout le monde soutient le gouvernement
et surtout ces mesures sanitaires contre
le coc vie 19
merci un mot monsieur regnard de
préciser oui merci monsieur le président
je fais l'ambassadeur choc excellence
jeu je voudrais juste avoir deux
précisions vous avez bien dit que tous
les passagers qu'ils soient de
nationalité coréenne ou pays tiers sont
tous testés à l'arrivée à l'aéroport
ça c'est la première confirmation que je
voulais avoir d'autre part tous testés
et la deuxième c'est vous avez mentionné
un résultat en 24 heures que faites vous
des passagers pendant ces périodes de 24
heures d'attentes des résultats merci
oui tout à fait bonne écoute toutes les
personnes arrivant sur le territoire
coréen qu'il soit coréen étrangers sont
tous testés à leur arrivée à l'aéroport
et vous avez aimé une très bonne
question
pendant ces 24 heures la côte près de
l'aéroport nous avons des établissements
dédiés pour que ces personnes attendent
le résultat
dis donc comme une console qui guide son
caddie et dont un des seaux d'eau
camions pour le transport entre
l'aéroport et ses établissements comme
il ya aussi encore un risque de
contamination
les transports les moyens de transport
sont préparés sont effectivement pris en
charge par le gouvernement également
merci pour ces précisions deuxième salve
de questions roger karoutchi encore
encore demi heure j'ai pas l'intention
de prendre une demi heure oui jusque sur
messieurs les ambassadeurs
moi j'ai eu une nièce qui a vécu avec
son mari et ses deux jeunes enfants en
corée du sud
jusqu'il ya un mois ils sont rentrés
encore u2 à paris ya un mois wood
février
c'est nous de paris qui étions inquiet
pour eux à partir du mois de mars
c e de séoul qui était inquiet pour nous
depuis qu'ils sont rentrés ils sont
sidérés par le laisser-aller par
l'absence de sécurité sanitaire en
france il n'était pas inquiet en ayant
leurs enfants scolarisés à séoul
il sont paniqués par la scolarisation
ici à paris alors je vais poser une
question à chacun des deux ambassadeurs
et ils répondront dans la limite de ce
qu'ils peuvent dire du fait de leurs
fonctions monsieur l'ambassadeur de
corée excellence vous habitez paris et
vous savez parfaitement ce qui se passe
en corée
vous venez de le démontrer vous seriez
non pas conseiller scientifique mais
conseillé au cours du gouvernement
français quelles seraient vos deux
propositions pour réduire la force de la
pandémie sachant que vous avez eu ou 300
morts et que nous nous approchons les
40000 jeu l'ambassadeur de france en
corée excellence vous connaissez
évidemment parfaitement la france mais
vous habitez à séoul
si vous étiez vous aussi conseillers du
gouvernement français je me permettrai
pas de penser vous puissiez être
conseiller du gouvernement coréen mais
si vous étiez conseillers du
gouvernement français
vu votre expérience et votre vécu à
séoul
quel serait pareil la mesure où les deux
mesures que vous proposeriez de fer avec
la recrudescence de la pandémie en
france on a bien compris il ya des
éléments d'unité de l'opinion publique
qui n'existe pas en france d'unités de
la vision médicale ou des autorités
quand vous dites monsieur l'ambassadeur
de corée que toutes les mesures qui ont
été prises n'ont engendré aucun débat ni
sur les masques ni sur les tests ni sur
aucune mesure
c'est sûr que on est loin du paysage
français mais quelles seraient les
mesures concrètes qui pourraient être
prises à partir de l'exemple coréen pour
maintenir un meilleur contrôle sur la
reprise de pandémie en france
merci jourdas merci monsieur le
président j'ai deux questions pour
monsieur l'ambassadeur de la république
de corée est une question pour monsieur
l'ambassadeur de france
la première question est sur le stock de
réserve que vous avez évoqué tout à
l'heure je voulais savoir quelle était
l'importance de ce stock est ce qu'il
s'agit de fournir uniquement les
professionnels de santé ou également
l'ensemble de la population
et quel est le délai d'autonomie prévu
étant précisé que j'ai bien compris que
des équipements de protection
individuelle était aussi fabriqué en
corée
ma deuxième question porte sur
l'organisation hospitalière qui a été
évoqué tout à l'heure qu'avez vous fait
de l'activité habituelle et de
l'activité programmée des hôpitaux
pendant cette période
et enfin la dernière question à monsieur
l'ambassadeur de france complète un peu
celle de
mon prédécesseur roger karoutchi quelle
communication avez-vous faites au
gouvernement français de la crise
sanitaire qui arrivaient encore et
qu'ils risquaient d'être mondiale et
avez vous communiquer ou avez vous été
interrogé sur la façon dont cette crise
sanitaire était traitée en corée et en
rappeler que cette abbaye qui avait déjà
connu des crises sanitaires et qui avait
donc de l'expérience en la matière merci
jean françois rapin
oui monsieur le président merci une
question qui s'impose de fait à monsieur
l'ambassadeur de corée pierce puisque il
évoque dans son propos un sujet qui
m'intéresse particulièrement qui est
celui de la plage et des vacances alors
vous évoquez vous évoquez monsieur
monsieur l'ambassadeur
le fait que la mairie de busan avait
pris certaines mesures justement pour
pour éviter la propagation du virus
en période en période de vacances en
france nous avons travaillé à l'époque
dur confinement avec le ministère
concerné et l'association dont je suis
président qui est qui et l'association
nationale des élus du littoral sur un
document qui permettait à la fois au
préfet au maire de pouvoir avoir un
recours finement dans les meilleures
conditions possibles
il semble que tout ça soit devenu
obsolète avec la ferveur et les
exagérations estivale et on pense qu'une
partie du phénomène de reprise virale
vient du fait d' delà de la promiscuité
sur les plages et sur les stations
balnéaires
pouvez-vous me décliner un petit peu
plus précisément monsieur l'ambassadeur
toutes les mesures qui ont été prises en
dehors de celles que je constate dans
votre propos qui est là le port du
masque chez nous ça a été très difficile
de pouvoir faire porter le masque sur
les plages
c'est même quasiment impossible sur les
digues un peu plus facilement mais je
voudrais savoir quels ont été les à la
fois les les autres moyens qui ont
permis de de contracter une certaine
certaine résilience au virus mais aussi
les moyens qui ont été ceux qui vous ont
permis de vérifier que ces mesures
étaient bien appliquée merci beaucoup
monsieur le président armée question
s'adresse aux deux ambassadeurs
la première concerne les données
personnelles la gestion la protection et
la maîtrise des données personnelles ont
été évoqués alors est-ce que
l'identification faciale fait partie de
la législation chez vous et ma deuxième
question concerne ni laboratoire p3 qui
ont été évoqués alors est-ce que
l'anticipation
tous les laboratoires sont classés
pitois sont de type et toi ou alors est
ce qu'il y a seulement laboratoire de
recherche de l'institut pasteur qui est
considéré comme étant pitois merci merci
jean sol oui monsieur le président
messieurs les ambassadeurs
j'ai deux questions la première
concernant la mise en place du cac cdc
en 2004
si j'ai bien compris est-ce que vous
pouvez nous nous en donner la
composition et le niveau des ressources
financières et humaines pour que cette
structure fonctionne ma deuxième
question s'agissant des cop confirmez
vous préciser qu'ils sont suivis par les
équipes d' enquête épidémiologique du
cac cdc
cela veut-il dire que les autres
épidémiologiste du pays sont occultés
dans le process ou pas je vous remercie
merci monsieur le fort
monsieur l'ambassadeur vous êtes avec
nous bon voilà excusez moi je vais
simplement pas nîmes en micro merci
monsieur le président merci sa ligne
wetter kabuki voilà je réponds de la
manière la plus directe la question vous
avez bien voulu me poser je crois que
vraiment de la différence fondamentale
entre l' approche disons coréenne l
approche européenne parce que en fin de
compte nous avons beaucoup communiqué
notamment avec nos collègues allemands
et c'était un petit peu les mêmes
réactions qu'on sentait c'est la
question de l'utilisation des données
des opérateurs pour le traçage des
déchets de contamination je crois que
encore et on a eu affaire à vraiment
comme l'a dit l'ambassadeur chez à un
absolu consensus sur la nécessité de
donner au centre de crise constitue le
cas ces décès tous les moyens pour
remonter le plus vite possible les les
les clusters et les chefs de
contamination de façon à atteindre le
plus rapidement possible des frais au
moment il se manifestait et ceci je
crois n'a posé de questions ni au public
ni aux aux partis politiques ni au
relais d'opinion élan alors qu'en france
je j'ai sorti moi-même dans la
correspondance que j'avais avec les
autorités mais aussi en allemagne dont
la plupart des pays européens une très
grande réticence à l'idée de confier ces
données à une administration alors que
par ailleurs je voudrais attirer votre
attention sur le fait que le règlement
général pour la protection des données
comprend une exception passiez de
consentement liés notamment la lutte
contre les épidémies selon des
formulations qui sont très voisines
en fin de compte des dispositions
législatives adoptées en 2015 après
l'épidémie ners et au calme
l'ambassadeur tchèque faisait faisait
référence
et là je crois qu'il ya vraiment une
une différence fondamentale d'approché
de sensibilité qui me semble vraiment
refléter un état d'esprit différent
entre les deux pays je crois qu'il ya un
niveau de confiance du public coréen à
l'égard non seulement du gouvernement
mais je dirais d'administration qui va
au-delà de ce que de ce qu'il peut se
manifester en france
je crois que c'est vraiment malade à la
différence fondamentale
bon je pense que quand on refera
l'histoire de cette crise il faudrait
sans doute réfléchir à des dispositifs
qui nous permette de consentir cette
exception
tout tend naturellement en mettant en
place les dispositifs les garanties la
présence de tiers de confiance qui
permettent effectivement de s'assurer du
bon usage de ces données personnelles
pour les besoins coût de la lutte contre
les fidji la joute et c'est mon dernier
point que ce qui est frappant aussi
encore et c'est que jamais le soupçon de
a priori de détournement des données
personnelles par castrés décès et ya
jamais eu de demande notamment de
présence d'un tiers de confiance auprès
de ses fonctionnaires pour s'assurer
effectivement pu donner des biens
utilisés ou feinte ou qu elle s était
destiné leur destruction était était
bien faite à l'issue de leur
exploitation
merci monsieur charest burundi visuel
alors pour les équipements de protection
individuelle
il n'y a pas vraiment eu de pénurie
c'était seulement à cause en fait la
production n'avait pas eu de problème
c'était seulement un problème de
d'approvisonnement et puis à cause du de
l'achat de panique qui a eu lieu mais
l'offre était bien sûr beaucoup plus
importante que la demande donc on
n'avait pas vraiment eu de problème même
pour les vêtements de protection et
concernant les masques
il y à un filtre m blosne filtre mb qui
sert dans les masques ce filtre l'heure
on en a suffisamment en face aux
composants là donc on n'a jamais
vraiment eu de problème pour les masquer
concernant les hôpitaux dédié au co vide
bien sûr pour les hôpitaux qu'il y avait
un risque de contamination donc pour les
patients qui étaient déjà dans des
hôpitaux enfin normaux je dirais
devaient être transférés dans d'autres
hôpitaux quand l'hôpital son hôpital
allait être dédiée au vide
concernant la question sur la plage de
haeundae à boue sable
moi personnellement je suis allé à
biarritz cet été et c'est vrai que j'ai
été un peu étonné par rapport au port du
masque parce que je voyais que les gens
n'en portaient pratiquement pas mais à
busan la distanciation de deux mètres
physique était strictement respecté les
parasols il y en a
50% moins que l'an dernier
donc voilà il ya différentes mesures qui
ont été mis en place et pour les
vacanciers aux coréens en général il
respectait tous les mesures sanitaires
en fait c'est quelque chose d'un peu
évident encore et donc je peux pas jouer
plus mais voilà la ville de busan été a
été a réagi efficacement c'est c'était
vraiment des mesures qui ont été
comprises par toute la population dont
qui ont été acceptés largement
concernant votre question de la
reconnaissance faciale non on n'est pas
allés jusque là s'est il y en avait que
des caméras de surveillance qui ont été
utilisés pour le traçage mais ce que je
voudrais vous dire c'est que hier matin
vous vous levez vous allez vous sortez
de votre lit si je vous demande quel a
été votre parcours est ce que vous en
rappeler en fait en général on s'en
rappelle pas et quand on vous demande
qu'est ce que vous avez fait il ya
exactement une semaine où êtes vous allé
à quelle heure précisément personne
n'est capable de répondre à cette
question s'en souvient pas donc avec les
technologies numériques d'information de
communication comme par exemple le
traçage avec des cartes bleues le mobile
la géolocalisation
avec tout cela ça ne sert donc tracé est
en fait c'est vraiment avec c'est ça en
fait qui sert à la personne
de se rappeler exactement où elle est
allée ce qu'elle a fait parce que sinon
elle ne se rappellerait pas mais c'est
pas quelque chose de très intrusif en
fait c'est vraiment une aide pour aider
à la personne pour lui dire où elle
était et ce qu'elle a fait pour qu'elle
se rappelle de ce qu'elle a fait
exactement il y a quelques jours
en fait pendant le confinement
quand j'étais ici j'ai relu la peste
d'albert camus c'est un chef-d'oeuvre
littéraire et sage j'ai commencé à
réfléchir beaucoup de choses à la
liberté individuelle aux relations
[Musique]
humaines à la signification de la mort a
remis au nom du dr
et même si la lutte contre le coc vide a
été efficace en corée et que la liberté
individuelle
si en fait on pouvait bien sûr respecter
la liberté individuelle à 100% et que la
lutte puisse être efficace à 100% ça
serait super mais en fait
malheureusement ce n'est malheureusement
pas possible donc il s'agit peut-être
d'un point en tout cas qui peut aider à
une lutte un peu plus efficace alors en
tout cas le parlement coréen prend en
compte l'avis des citoyens coréens et
encore est également aussi on a eu nos
libertés individuelles on tient à nos
données personnelles à notre vie privée
on les respecte c'est quelque chose qui
est très important ce sont des valeurs
fortes mais malheureusement face aux
colons renard et virus quand on est dans
un état de crise on a besoin de ça ni de
mesures sanitaires très forte stricte
également pour pouvoir protéger la
population
seulement dans ce but là et donc même si
notre système aujourd'hui n'est pas à
100% idéal mais en tout cas c'est un
moindre mal et le parlement a obtenu
seulement ce consensus pour faire passer
cette loi
merci en ce qui le concerne et me taire
et hawk ac dc où il est environ 1000
personnes
il y environ 100 enquêteurs
épidémiologique et la plupart deux sont
des médecins des docteurs ils sont
sélectionnés et dans les collectivités
locales également il y a des médecins
qui prennent la fonction enfin le rôle
de l'enquêteur épidémiologique avec
cette épidémie on a compris qu'il y en
avait pas assez donc le cas cdc va être
renforcé cette semaine et c'est pour ça
qu'il y aura encore plus d'enquêteurs
épidémiologique
merci vous n'avez pas déprogrammée de
malades qu'ils devaient subir des
interventions qui ont été annulés deux
pour donner la priorité aux manades
qu'ovide oui oui heureusement
heureusement encore et contrairement à
plusieurs pays européens n'est pas si
grave
il y en avait très peu
donc au plus fort de la crise on a eu
160 patients graves
donc on n'a pas vraiment eu de report
d'opérations d'urgence de ces patients
là est également la population avait
peut-être aussi un peu peur d'être
contaminés quand elle se rendait dans
les hôpitaux ce qui fait que la
population ne se rendait pas vraiment
dans les hôpitaux à ce moment là et pour
soulager également la charge des
hôpitaux
on ne voulait pas que le système les
hôpitaux s'effondre mais en tout cas on
avait vraiment très peu de patients
graves pendant la crise et pour vous
dire en fait en cours et la
téléconsultation est interdite il faut
absolument qu'il y à un face à face avec
le patient et le docteur mais pendant la
crise pour la première fois la
téléconsultation a été rendue possible
donc le corona virus n'a pas réussi en
tout cas faire effondrer le système de
santé corps ayant heureusement merci
merci monsieur l'ambassadeur
monsieur le fort une petite précision
notre collègue muriel jourda vous avez
demandé si vous aviez été interrogé en
la france sur les mesures prises en
corée oui bien entendu sur le président
nous avons alimenté les pouvoirs publics
français y compris du reste la
présidence des présidents des assemblées
parlementaires avec toute la formation
qui était mise à notre disposition nous
recherchons encore et je jeu notamment
nous avons beaucoup correspondu sur
l'organisation du gacd c est notamment
l'exploitation des données
nous avons aussi disons donner des
jugements enfin fait des évaluations
notamment dès le 15 mars et nous est
apparu que le système de traçage des
chaîne de contamination avait fait la
preuve de son efficacité après la
maîtrise du cluster de john est
démontrée effectivement on pouvait l
être de ces de cette méthodologie éviter
d'être débordés par une circulation
incontrôlée du vieux c'est enfoncer ses
sables l'élément fondamental que
personnellement nous retenons cette
crise c'est que effectivement la crise
est effectivement l'exploitation de
l'information
c'est ce qui a permis aux autorités
coréennes d'éviter d'être débordé qu'il
s'agisse des ressources hospitalières
des ressources humaines ou de la
nécessité de peser trop haut trop
durement sur l'économie merci une
précision encore catherine des roches
dures excellence vous nous parler du 15
mars mais ces échanges d'informations
avaient démarré dès le 20 janvier délais
le premier cas dans votre fille chez le
fort mais sur les gens voient notre
correspondance mais oui nous avons nous
avons nous avons menées nous avons nous
avons correspondu manière moyenne de br
/ sur les dispositifs prix sur prix en
corée sur l'évolution de la crise bien
sûr nous avons nous sommes efforcés
d'envoyer toutes les informations de
l'opposition
dernière précision monsieur lefort vous
nous avez parlé de 430 personnes dans le
cas c'est enfin la structure les
structures le coréenne mille personnes
nous dit l'ambassadeur me choque alors
ses 430 ou ses mille feux
c'est les deux c'est le je crois que le
chiffre donné par par l'ambassadeur
dessus ça comprend l'ensemble du
personnel affecté à l'heure actuelle ou
casser les c qu'il s'agisse du personnel
permanent ou du personnel temporaire
puisque une partie des effectifs ont été
prélevés sur le reste des
administrations pour faire face à la
crise
par exemple
on a eu un certain nombre de nos
collègues du ministère coréen des
affaires étrangères qui ont été affectés
ou kcdc à des fins justement en
communication avec nous et avec les
interlocuteurs étrangers
le gym de 430 match est celui qui m'a
été donnée alors très précisément au
mois de mai pour s'agissant des des
personnes chargées de la collecte et de
l'intégration des données bien que ça
correspond aux personnages ce qui bon
gré j'ai les tableaux excel en avant
effectivement l'industrialisation du
processus et sont sauvés l'utilisation
du système d'information géographique et
ça comprenez les personnels de vous
connaissez c'est proprement dit mais
également le correspondant auprès des
des autorités territoriales chargées
notamment de du recueil des informations
relatif ou ou cas positive et aucun
contact
merci pour ces précisions je crois que
nos commissaires sont satisfaits
développant une dernière petite question
très rapide n'est pas eu des réponses
concernant les pétoires les la braderie
exact merci les laboratoire p3 tous les
laboratoires sont en p3 ou seulement les
laboratoires de recherche telle était la
question mais je sais pas
personnellement en mesure de vous
répondre
t3 cela correspond à un niveau de
sécurité très le maximum c'est des gars
du laboratoire de quoi vous le savez là
je ne serais pas vous répondre je pense
que c'est à niveau qui n'était
accessible que la recherche
universitaire au public de haut niveau
je sais que le laboratoire de deux lits
pk et petra je ne sais pas merci en tout
cas c'est une réponse qui peut être
fournie par écrit merci n'hésitez pas
nous vous en à nous envoyer les écrits
nécessaire merci merci monsieur de
france encore et merci à toutes et tous
nous sommes dans le timing puisque
maintenant nous allons recevoir nos
intervenants de taïwan
merci à 11h dans quelques minutes
merci voilà vous avez pu suivre les
échanges
la situation république de corée et ce
matin les travaux de la commission
denquête se poursuivre
je vous propose de suivre à présent les
échanges sur la situation à taïwan
on se retrouve après donc nous
poursuivons nos nos travaux et qui vont
être maintenant consacrer à la gestion
de la crise à taïwan
[Musique]
je prie d'excuser le président milon qui
est retenu dans son département et ce
matin nous allons entendre françois
xichang ou représentant de taiwan en
france et monsieur jean françois
casabonne maso nav représentant de la
france à taïwan
merci de nombreux éléments nous
intéresse bien sûr dans la gestion de la
crise
à taiwan la géographie a sans doute
rendu nécessaire une alerte précoce dans
la gestion d'épidémie et la mise en
place rapide de contrôle aux frontières
au-delà fort de l'expérience des
épidémies deux tracés demers et de la
résilience de la population le pays a
mis en place une stratégie de protection
d'isolement et de traçage qui
semble-t-il a permis d'éviter le
confinement
quels ont été les orientations retenues
en matière de tests la pénurie
d'équipements de protection at elle été
ressenti comment les lieux accueillant
des personnes fragiles en particulier
les personnes âgées ont ils été géré
voilà quelques questions qui vont vous
être posée
je vous demanderais d'intervenir de
façon concise pour dix minutes de faire
un propos introductif chacun ensuite
nous passerons aux questions de nos
trois commissaires puis nos questions
trois rapporteurs pendant puis aux
questions de nos commissaires mais
conformément à la procédure d' enquête
je vais vous demander de prêter serment
jeu sachant que tout mensonge et une
commission denquête est passible de
prison cinq ans et d'une amende de 75
mille euros donc monsieur jean françois
casabonne maso nav
je rêve ou de dire la vérité toute la
vérité levé la main droite et dire je le
jure je le jure merci et monsieur
j'essaye de ne pas encore chez votre
françois ou ne prête pas serment vous
m'en excuser du fait que c'est un
représentant de taiwan en france merci
voilà alors sans plus tarder je vous
passe la parole et comment ce monsieur
vous eh bien vous avez la parole
monsieur vous un bouton
d'abord celui là très bien merci alors
monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs mesdames et
messieurs je vous remercie de votre
invitation qui me permet d'apporter un
éclairage sur la gestion de la crise
ducobu 19 ted qu'elle a été traitée à
taïwan
je m'efforcerai d'être le plus précis
possible mais je reste à votre
disposition pour répondre à
d'éventuelles questions
je vais d'abord présenté la situation
actuelle appelle one très simple pour
pour permettre de mieux connaître notre
situation
alors taïwan est un état d'une
population de 24 millions d'habitants
c'est à dire deux fois la belgique ou si
vous connaissez bien l'asie pacifique
c'est exactement la taille de
l'australie le pib de taiwan hébergement
est déjà supérieur à celui de la suède
et au niveau commercial nous importons
plus que l'australie la russie et le
brésil et nous exportons plus que la
suisse la belgique l'espagne et l'inde
taïwan est une île dont la superficie
équivaut celle des pays-bas ou celle de
la belgique
il est à noter que taiwan n'a jamais
était confiné et que la croissance
économique s'est maintenu à un taux de
1,5 pour cent pour cette année taïwan
est également séparé de la chine par un
des trois de large de 150 km et des
échanges double de part et d'autre sont
denses 40%
échanges commerciaux de taiwan se font
avec la chine en 2010 9 2008 7 millions
de chinois se sont déplacés à taîwan
pour tourisme et chaque année quatre
millions de tergnier voyage en chine
pourtant depuis d'apparition ducobu 19
powell n'a recensé à ce jour que 495 cas
confirmés sept personnes sont décédées
et 13 personnes sont actuellement à
l'hôpital pour une mise en quarantaine
des raisons pour laquelle tf1 a réussi à
endiguer de virus pour le moment
s'articule autour de six points que je
vais détailler premier expérience tirer
les leçons du passé
taïwan a été un des pays les plus
touchés par l'épidémie de sras en 2003 à
l'époque 346 personnes ont été infectées
et 81 81
quatre-vingt-une sont décédés soit un
taux de plus de 20% de létalité à
l'époque
bernanke de coordination entre le
gouvernement central et local un hôpital
municipal de taipei a été confiné
causant la mort de sept professionnels
et des suicides des images
apocalyptiques de personnes confinées
voulant forcer la ligne de confinement
et la directrice municipale de la santé
portant une combiner une combinaison
spatiale pour entrer à l'hôpital ont
traumatisé la population de taiwan
deuxième point vigilance dès l'aube du
31 décembre 2019
powell a exprimé des doutes le ms sur la
possibilité d'un virus transmissible
entre humains haouran en chine à partir
du 31 décembre 2019
le ministère de la santé est erroné
commencé à effectuer des prises de
température systématique et des examens
complets pour des cas suspects dès
l'atterrissage des vols en provenance de
roanne puis très rapidement sur tous les
vols en provenance de chine et jusqu'à
la fermeture complète des frontières
le 25 janvier le gouvernement taïwanais
décide de fermer les frontières aux
touristes chinois
tous les trous tous les groupes de
touristes chinois à taiwan ont dû
repartir avant le 31 janvier le 7
février
interdiction d'entrée pour les
ressortissants étrangers qui se sont
rendus en chine au cours des 14
dernières jours le 18 mars a
interdiction d'entrer sur le territoire
pour les ressortissants étrangers et 14h
pour tous les voyageurs taîwanais entre
en troisième point efficacité activation
du centre disent entre central de
commandement
on appelle centre de commandement
central des épidémies à partir du 20
janvier 2020 sous la responsabilité du
ministre de la santé le ministre dispose
de toutes les ressources du gouvernement
y compris la possibilité de mobiliser de
l'armée si nécessaire
quatrième point confiance la
transparence des informations ainsi ré
confiance à la population une conférence
de presse présidée par le ministre de la
santé lui même pendant 140 jours
consécutifs et tonique quotidiennement
et les journalistes peuvent poser des
questions illimitée cela a permis de
rassurer la population sur la pandémie
est de combattre manipulation
d'informations
cinquième point masque indépendance
rapide de la production des masques
avant taïwan comme en france
payne dépendait beaucoup de la
production des masques en chine mais
actuellement est le deuxième plus grand
pays du monde producteur producteurs de
masquer le 31 janvier le gouvernement
décide de mettre en place une équipe
nationale spécifique dédié aux copies
dix neuf il réquisitionne et supervise
l'installation de 92 chaîne de
production supplémentaire pour faire
passer la production de masques de 2 à
20 millions d'unités par jour
le 3 avril le gouvernement taïwanais
décrète le port de masque obligatoire
pour les usagers d'autres des transports
en commun
y compris dans les taxis le dernier
point c'est le sujet point technologie
une politique de mise en 14 est très
stricte pour les personnes soupçonnées
d'être infectées pour améliorer le suivi
des voyageurs entrant le guen antoine et
à imposer une déclaration de santé
obligatoire à tous les passagers à leur
arrivée une déclaration inexacte est
passible d'une amende pouvant aller
jusqu'à 4500 euros
cette déclaration obligatoire a permis
de classer les voyageurs dans
différentes catégories à risque et de
mettre en oeuvre une politique de
quarantaine adapter une fois passée une
fois placé en tête hors zone tout
individu est dans l'obligation de
respecter les consignes strictes sous
peine de six mois de prison ferme et 30
mille euros damende le gouvernement
n'est fournie aux personnes mises en cas
de rosen un téléphone portable qui
permet de faire de faire respecter
l'interdiction totale de sortie du
domicile
ce système a permis également au
gouvernement taïwanais de prioriser les
tests sur les personnes présentant les
symptômes karaté est il du coronavirus
le recours à d'application des
technologies est autorisé par l'article
7 de la loi spéciale de prévention
ducobu 19 assistances et de relance
adopté le 25 février 2020 qui permet au
commandant du centre de mettre en oeuvre
toutes les mesures d'urgence nécessaires
pour prévenir et contrôler l'épidémie
je conclure points à gagner pour le
moment une première bataille contre
d'argovie 19 mai n'a pas encore gagné de
la guerre
l'opinion publique térénez exige que le
gouvernement utilise tous les moyens à
sa disposition pour endiguer le virus en
dehors des frontières nationales sans
confinement général de la population
la prospérité de taiwan dépend fortement
de ses échanges avec le monde extérieur
dans ce contexte il est crucial pour
taiwan de trouver un équilibre
d'ouverture des frontières avec la
communauté internationale
car le virus selon toute vraisemblance
ne va pas disparaître dans le futur
proche et va continuer à circuler
c'est un défi auquel taiwan doit faire
face nous pensons néanmoins qu'il est
très difficile de porter un regard sur
les ponce d'un autre pays qui a ses
propres facteurs et ses spécificités à
prendre en compte pour limiter la
propagation du virus
pour autant dans un monde où les
échanges entre cher pays ne font
qu'augmenter
il serait indispensable de pouvoir
partager à travers la plateforme tant
bilatérale que multilatérale les
expériences dans la lutte contre cette
crise sanitaire
il ne connaît pas de frontières je pense
que cette invitation de la commission
denquête au sénat constitue d'ores et
déjà une première étape vers l'intérêt
commun commun pour nos deux pays et de
l'humanité
je remercie de votre attention merci
merci merci pour vos propos monsieur
casabonne massonnat 20 merci monsieur le
président nous sommes convenus avec mon
ami et collègue françois ou que je
compléterai son propos sans répéter ce
qui a été dit qui reflète parfaitement
notre propre expérience
le bureau de représentation de la france
à taïwan quelques remarques donc très
ciblée la première qui est le point
saillant marquant c'est que l'expérience
de taiwan est à ma connaissance assez
unique
c'est à dire voilà un une île une
population nombreuse comme 1,23 million
et demi d'habitants 24 millions qui est
directement exposé à la pandémie qui
réagit immédiatement et qui est qui en
est encore un thème plus de huit mois
après le début de la pandémie
à peine 500 cas et cette mort donc c'est
vraiment une expérience très
exceptionnel et qui tient d'abord et
avant tout françois l'a expliqué à
l'anticipation c'est à dire que avant
tout début de manifestation
tout le monde depuis le chef de l'état
jusque
à chaque citoyen en passant par les
entreprises en passant par les
collectivités locales
tout le système de santé etc tout le
monde était prêt c'est très
impressionnant de ce point de vue là et
on voit bien effectivement que la clé
c'est le traumatisme du strass qui en
2003 qui a profondément traumatisé tout
le monde il y avait eu dans un autre
contexte
en 99 un tremblement de terre qui avait
fait de très graves dégâts y compris mme
à taïwan et là aussi il ya une reprise
en main de tous les dispositifs d'alerté
et de sécurité et bien face au risque de
pandémie
taiwan s'était donné les moyens en
permanence d'être d'être d'être prêt
avec c'est un point que françois ou
décrit également avec cette conscience
que dans une société démocratique
l'efficacité du dispositif dépend très
fortement de la relation de confiance de
la population envers les autorités
ça c'est quelque chose qui m'a été
répété à plusieurs reprises plutôt dans
un deuxième temps après avril mais quand
ils ont senti je parle des autorités en
confiance or certains résultats
ils ont commencé à expliquer de manière
très précise à quel point le point
d'information quotidien que faisait le
ministre de la santé et habdomadaire
aujourd'hui et qui était suivi par toute
la population était suivi avec une très
très grande niveau d'attention et de
détails
le ministre de la santé aujourd'hui à
des niveaux de popularité qui dépassait
80 % 90 % ça a marché
ça n'est pas anecdotique c'est un point
majeur de la stratégie des autorités
taïwanaises pour faire face à ce péril
le deuxième exemple que je voulais cité
c'est la stratégie s'agissant des
masques effectivement début janvier
quand les autorités font le constat
qu'il ya un risque qu'ils commencent à
être sérieusement identifiés font aussi
le constat que leur production nationale
de masques ne n'est pas suffisante 2
millions quotidiennement et que
l'objectif qu'il faut se donner ses 20
millions cet objectif est atteint fermer
début juin ça signifie que dès le mois
de janvier janvier rien je dis bien
le ministère des finances a débloqué des
crédits qu'il a donné au ministère de
l'industrie qui est allé acheter les
machines les chaînes de montage en
allemagne l'armée a été mobilisée pour
monter ses chaînes de montage dans
quelques semaines et tout ça a été mis à
disposition des industriels
un industriel taiwan et c'est un énorme
savoir-faire de production en masse de
très grande qualité
donc c'était eux les mieux placés et non
pas des services publics ou des
administrations pour traiter la
fabrication industrielle du process mais
avec des moyens qui ont été mobilisés au
niveau du gouvernement et à partir de là
la montée en puissance s'est fait
exactement comme planifié moi je me suis
rendu au ministère des affaires
économiques
début mars il était très serein est
d'ailleurs assez ouvert partager leurs
expériences pour pour tous ceux qui
pourraient qui pourraient le demander et
donc la gestion des masses s'est aussi
accompagnée par un rationnement qui a
également permis aussi de contrôler la
pression de la population et
d'approvisionner chaque individu de
manière efficace voilà ce sont deux
points un peu concrets que j'ai souhaité
porter à votre connaissance parce que il
est clair cette manière tout à fait
spécifique un chaque pays chaque nation
sa propre expérience celle de taiwan ce
n'est pas un mystère cette ce résultat
extraordinaire pour le moment tient à
des raisons objectives et tout à fait
rationnel et bien sûr le dernier point
france aurait conclu là dessus c'est
qu'aujourd'hui taiwan se retrouvent une
certaine manière un peu piégé par la
qualité de sa gestion de la crise
c'est à dire qu'aujourd'hui la
population ne supporte pas l'idée que le
virus parviennent à entrer et donc les
dispositifs de contrôle ce sous le sous
l'autorité du ministre de la santé
sont extrêmement rigoureux ils sont
transparents là aussi des règles du jeu
qui sont pas méconnu enfin qui sont tout
à fait accessible quand on veut se
rendre à taïwan maison extrêmement
rigoureuse et la population est
extrêmement vigilante et donc bien sûr
tous les milieux économiques
moi j'ai assisté dans juillet une
réunion organisée par le ministre des
affaires étrangères joseph ou avec la
nouvelle ministre des affaires
économiques avec le ministre chen de la
santé l'objet de cette réunion avec les
autres représentants européens s'étaient
d'expliquer au ministre de la santé
du point de vue des européens pourquoi
il fallait être un petit peu plus
souples vis-à-vis des entreprises en
particulier
donc on voit bien que cette tension là
elles demeurent et que ça va être un
enjeu pour taiwan aujourd'hui 2 qui est
une économie ouverte ouverte sur
l'international et qui fonctionne on est
encore à espérer que taiwan par un taux
de croissance positif cette année
le chômage atteint des sommets c'est à
dire 4 % en 1 4 % de chômage en pleine
crise donc c'était économie qui
fonctionne extrêmement bien mais qui ne
peut pas se permettre de vivre fermé
trop longtemps voilà monsieur le
président ce que je voulais porter à la
connaissance de l'assemblée
merci beaucoup pour la précision de ses
propos je passe la parole aux
rapporteurs catherine des roches
merci monsieur le président et merci à
vous deux représentants de
de ces précisions j'avais une question
concernant les tests au départ les tests
étaient effectués sur les personnes
présentant des symptômes
et d'après ce que j'ai lu au fil du
temps ça a été élargi même à des
personnes asymptomatiques quelle est la
situation actuelle par rapport aux tests
de dépistage est le deuxième point
concerne les traitements
j'ai lu aussi que lors md et vire et est
beaucoup utilisé comme traitement
avez-vous les études cliniques des
résultats du remdh et vire et ou
d'autres traitements qui auraient pu
être appliquée j'ai vu qu'il y avait eu
un remplacement un temps par la
dexaméthasone donc est-ce que vous
pouvez nous donner un peu une idée des
des thérapeutiques des essais cliniques
et des traitements actuels voilà c'est
simplement les deux questions j'avais
président merci monsieur vous je pense
ce n'est pas une nous ce que la
stratégique le terrain c'est de faire
c'est de d'endiguer le virus à
l'extérieur alors ça a été aussi un
grand débat être il fallait faire des
dépistages général alors le ministère le
ministre sentez insisté que la société
one c'est d'abord quand les personnes
entrant ap one
il fallait d'abord faire un condiment de
14 jours dont il est un des cinq hommes
qui sort d'un on pourrait aller tester
dont il n'y a pas vraiment de dépistage
général dont se sont vraiment dépistage
ciblé pour des personnes qui présentent
quelques symptômes
alors bien sûr des gens qui sont en
contact avec des personnages qui sont
confiées confirme hélas on les fait
aussi
alors si quelqu'un n'importe quelle
personne ou vais savoir si lui il a été
atteint du virus
ils pourraient ils pourraient se faire
tester à ses frais donc c'est un peu
près comme ça que ça fonctionne à taïwan
le débat dit que si on fait un dépistage
général le système de santé telle est
même très performants ne pourra pas
supporter et ils ont vu un peu aussi le
cas de l'allemagne
donc sur ce point là je pense c'est une
stratégie un peu différent des autres
pays
si on est on les confine d'abord pendant
quatorze chars persona même j'ai un ami
qui était ambassadeur en thaïlande
et maintenant qui est devenu ministre
pour les rentrées à taïwan il a été
aussi confiné pendant 14 jours
il a pris ses fonctions dans son hôtel
de confinement et donc c'est sûr ce sera
déjà que tu as one fonctionne
le deuxième point je suis
peut-être jean-françois peut répondre on
partage un peu alors oui sur le premier
point enfin sur les deux questions
ce qu'il faut toujours conserver à
l'esprit c'est que l'on parle taiwan de
toutes petites quantités
donc on n'aura jamais des réponses à ce
type de questions qui nous aideront ici
en france construire une stratégie dans
la mesure où les différents traitements
qui seront appliquées
c'est à quelques dizaines de personnes
viennent donc on est dans un contexte où
toutes les stratégies se construisent
une manière tout à fait différente et a
même moi je ne serais pas surpris je ne
peux pas aller beaucoup plus loin que ça
mais sur les traitements médicaux je
pense pas qu'il y ait une stratégie
générale qui était arrêté le niveau du
système de santé taïwanais est le plus
élevé au monde
l'un des plus élevés au monde voir le
plus élevé au monde votre serviteur a eu
la malchance de de le tester et
hospitalisé pendant cinq jours à la fin
d'année dernière
c'est vraiment un système remarquable
pour toute la population donc ensuite
une fois que on se retrouve en face de
ce genre de processus encore une fois
moins de 500 personnes décelée
ça veut dire à peine quelques dizaines
de personnes traitées
donc toutes ces questions statistiques
ou méthodologiques ou stratégiques de
face à la crise en vérité est un vrai ne
sont pas vraiment elle ne nous
apprennent pas grand chose à ce stade et
c'est l'un des problèmes bien sûr pour
tyrone dans le sur le volet de la
recherche
ils n'ont pas de malades sur lesquels
travailler ou très peu celui verbier
merci monsieur le président merci et un
autre représentant
juste une question par rapport à
l'activité économique
est-ce que vous avez un petit peu évoqué
le sujet est ce que vous avez eu besoin
de mettre en place un plan de relance de
quel montant et pour couvrir quel
secteur d'activité
est-ce que vous avez mis en place du
chômage partiel qu'elle évoquait leçon
vaut type 2
de soutien apporté à l'activité
économique merci
je pense même l'économie était one
fonctionne très bien nous avons quand
même eu besoin d'une relance et
économique parce que il y a pendant le
confinement même d'activité conique
fonctionne très bien mais il ya eu quand
même beaucoup de contrôles c'est à dire
par exemple des grands spectacles
sportifs ont aussi été annulés mais nous
avons été un des premiers à comprendre
alors c'est très intéressant vous voyez
des sur le spectacle qui avait personne
et des gens jouer là dedans et l'on
mettait des on-dit des mannequins sur
place il faut faire semblant ce qu'il y
avait des gens dans le spectacle donc et
le tourisme a aussi énormément souffert
donc cela il ya scénarii la communauté
ses talents de l'économie tenesol quand
même été endommagés alors on a lieu un
plan de relance qui a été annoncé je
crois de trente 30 milliards d'euros 30
milliards d'euros qui a été lancé par
par le gouvernement pour essayer
d'inciter les activités économiques et
je pense jean-françois pourra compléter
l'action parce qu'il est vraiment sur
place ce sont les chiffres que je peux
vous présenter que l'économie a été
atteint quand même ça reste un peu près
normal mais il ya quand même eu des
problèmes et donc de la secte
économiques demandent au gouvernement de
faire plus mais jean-françois sur place
je crois il la déclare très concrètes
pour vous dire comment ça marche et à
taïwan
merci ce président oui en effet alors
d'abord il faut conserver l'esprit que
taiwan c'était un état une société très
riche qui a les moyens de sa politique
sans peine endettés 35% je crois du pnb
qu'ils ont les capacités de mobilisation
financière énorme et un gouvernement qui
est on dirait de sensibilité sociale
démocrate dont il n'y a pas d'état d'âme
a déclenché des plans d'intervention
pour soutenir l'activité économique mais
aussi les actions sociales donc
effectivement certains secteurs de
l'économie en souffert les transports
internationaux bien sûr le tourisme est
en vérité après l'été on voit bien que
c'est passé comme ici du reste le fait
que les taiwanais qui sont des grands
voyageurs sont restés à taiwan et donc
ils ont remplacé les touristes étrangers
qui n'était plus là par contre le
tourisme d'affaires donc les grands
hôtel de taipei sont sinistrées seul et
puis toute la restauration pendant deux
mois ça a été vraiment très très
difficile mais le taïwanais je parle de
vendée taiwan et adore ripailler et ils
ont recommencé à aller dans les
restaurants en famille en ami donc tout
ça à redémarrer très vite ensuite donc
le plan de
2 les plans fait de soutien à l'économie
c'était très ciblée très très ciblées
dont qui a des soutiens certaine
population au chômage
il ya des plans de soutien à la
consommation avec notamment des systèmes
de bons qui sont un petit peu compliquée
à imaginer en france
mais ce sont des bons du gouvernement on
dépense mille ans dépensent milan reçoit
et on a une capacité d'achat de 3000 si
je me souviens bien
on doit d'abord dépenser
30 30 euros pour recevoir 100 d'euros de
la part du gouvernement enfin pour
pouvoir les consommer avant un certain
moment chaleureux
l'idée c'est que je le consommateur doit
d'abord aussi c'est pas uniquement avec
le gouvernement qu'on travaille c'est le
consommateur doit aussi dépenser
d'argent pour acheter des bons du
gouvernement est ensemble ça triple ce
que le consommateur à pap y ait à payer
au gouvernement et sa triple la
consommation de faveur de l'état est ce
que les plus important c'est que tout le
secteur économique s'est adapté aux issa
dont il ya encore des avantages qui ont
été faits imaginez pour encore rajouté
pour inciter la consommation à taïwan
dont ça c'est un plan qui avait été
imaginé par le gouvernement
autre exemple de l'action culturelle 1
dès le mois d'avril
des mesures ont été pris par le
ministère de la culture pour soutenir
les activités l'industrie culturelle
c'était très important pour les mêmes
difficultés que celles qu'on connaît en
france
et puis il ya aussi des secteurs
d'activité qui eux sont florissants
l'industrie taïwanaise aujourd'hui c'est
dans une large partie de l'industrie des
semi conducteurs
les puces dans tous vos téléphones il y
à des puces taïwanaise tous quelle que
soit la marque et le confinement partout
dans le monde fait que tout le monde a
acheté des tablettes des outils de
mobilité etc
ça fait exploser
l'industrie les commandes de l'industrie
des semi conducteurs au même moment le
l'impact des mesures américaines fait
que highway a cessé d'être un client dès
le deuxième client de tsmc qui est le
fleuron tsmc a perdu donc son deuxième
client après apple et leurs cours de
bourse explose parce qu'ils sont
vraiment florissant et donc certains
secteurs de l'industrie taïwanaise
bénéficie de la crise en vérité en ce
moment et en raison ou bien sûr de leur
avance technologique c'est pas là aussi
des raisons très concrètes voilà donc
les plans d'action les moyens d'action
que se sont donnés le gouvernement n'y a
pas de tabou en quelque sorte qu'ils
agissent partout où besoin est exprimée
de manière très concrète
merci dernière journée merci monsieur le
président je vous remercie tous les deux
pour pour vos explications et pour vos
exposés pour nous c'est une matinée très
intéressante parce que nous venons
d'auditionner l'ambassadeur de corée du
sud et notre ambassadeur et votre pays
vit une situation un peu avec des points
communs que même une proximité
géographique très forte avec l'origine
de l'épidémie
une capacité l'absence de frontières
terrestres tous les deux même si vous
vous êtes unis l'éclat corée du sud n'en
est pas une
et puis une mémoire très récente du fait
épidémique avec la succession hachana le
strass le maire c est donc c'est très
intéressant pour nous évidemment de voir
ce que cette expérience apprend
les sud coréens nous ont décrit un
système avec une agence le cas cfc si
j'ai bonne mémoire qui a été en
situation de pilotage il me semble qu'il
existe une agence je crois parce que
j'ai vu un écrit de notre ambassadeur
qui parle du ccc et vous n'en avez pas
du tout parlé là vous parlez d'un
pilotage strictement par le ministre de
la santé dit féministe de la santé qui
pilote de la crise donc est ce qu'il y a
donc vous pouvez nous en dire plus une
agence de santé publique elle et son
rôle comme un travail tel est ce que il
ya eu des controverses scientifiques
nous nous fait que nous avons vécu et
vivons encore en permanence des
controverses scientifiques qui ont un
impact sur l'adhésion et la
compréhension par la population
d'ailleurs est ce que vous avez vécu est
ce que vous vivez ce phénomène de
controverses scientifiques sur le masque
qu'elle est quelles sont les mesures qui
ont été prises
est il obligatoire en intérieur en
extérieur qu'elle est calé sa part est
ce que l'adhésion de la population a été
spontanée fait référence aux épidémies
antérieures ou est-ce qu'il a fallu
refaire un travail de d'appropriation de
de cette question et puis enfin la
dernière question est simplement pour
notre notre ambassadeur il ya les
politiques regard des contraintes
diplomatiques existantes
comment pensez vous que le fait quand
même très intéressant de ce qui se passe
à taiwan dans la gestion de la crise
peut être mieux partagée et mieux
bénéficier aux autres pays je remercie
merci
si monsieur jomier merci monsieur le
président concernant cette cellule de
crise
effectivement chez nous c'est vraiment
le ministre sentez qui pilote de tout ce
que je venais de vous expliquer qu'il
avait mis le pouvoir ne mobiliser
l'armée au cas nécessaire donc le centre
ce qu'on appelle le centre de
commandement central des épidémies c'est
un centre qui a été créé après la crise
du sras en 2003 après ça a été activée
parce qu'après il y avait plus de vie
d'amy donc ça n'a pas tellement
fonctionner mais après c'est à dire
réactiver le 20 janvier 2020 alors c'est
une sorte de centre qui qui réunit temps
de crise qui réunit tous les
spécialistes de la santé ils sont
surtout à des médecins ou des
spécialistes pour des épidémies et il ya
eu et comme vous l'avait indiqué dès
aussi des conflits à l'intérieur par
exemple pour la question dépistage alors
et seulement 6 passes et à taiwan c'est
que une ville qui est de l'opposition
est en opposition c'est aussi une
démocratie on a le parti au pouvoir et
qui appartient à l'opposition
le médecin a à a décidé lui même de
faire un dépistage massive pour voir si
vraiment le virus existent et où
n'existait pas au synthé roanne alors
que la sacrée vraiment une sorte de
polémique au sein de la société one pour
dire est-ce qu'il fallait utiliser les
ressources des tables pour faire ça et
puis ils n'avaient pas informé le
cellule à cellule centrale et ce sont
des conflits qui a été écrit et ça
prouve bien que ça existe est finalement
bon la décision ait appartenue tous les
to les villes ont dit qu ils écoutaient
ce centre de crise et une alfa il
n'avait pas faire de dépistage général
donc ça c'est de compter que je venais
pour répondre à qu'ils venaient poser
deuxième question c'était sur les
masques c'était et quelle est la
politique vous avez du mal catoire en
intérieur ou en extérieur alors les
masques ce que je vais vous dire aussi
la dé devenir obligatoire après mais au
début comme déjà on avait sensibilisé la
population dont la création avait déjà
cet institut c'est le sentiment qu'il
fallait pour des matchs parce que mon
avis il est urgent de strass en 2003
donc au début aussi le gouvenement comme
ils avaient confisqué tous les
industries et puis limité les masses que
chaque personne oppressant procurer mais
il assuré de chaque citoyen pouvait
avoir un certain nombre de marques et
après maintenant comme la production des
données suffisantes donc je pense déjà à
porter automatiquement il n'y a plus
aucun problème et même on avait pu avoir
cette sorte de coopération
internationale pour essayer de trouver
des causes y en ait deux pays comme on
avait
assistez l'europe a donné ce million de
masques en europe et plus 10 millions je
pense dans le pays entier à l'époque
c'est ouais voilà donc là on dit de même
capable aider les autres pays d'asie
c'était au mois d'avril je me souviens
le 1er avril donc voilà c'est à peu près
sept nains politiques de taïwan
la deuxième question c'est jean françois
qui va répondre ah oui pardon oui juste
sur le commentaire sur donc le ccc le
centre de crise donc c'était un
organisme qui est activé en cas de
besoin sinon qui est dormant et qui est
présidé par le ministère de la santé
puisque ce qu'a expliqué françois sur le
masque oui on est dans une société en
asie où le port du masque est une chose
naturelle quand on est un petit peu
souffrant l'idée un qui est très
éloignée des mentalités ici c'est je me
protège le protège les autres les autres
se protège il me protège donc c'est un
tous les débats sur la désocialisation
qui s'est passé exactement le contraire
le port du masque en asie c'est une
marque d'adhésion à la société
d'inclusion dans la société dans
laquelle on vit
et du coup tout le monde porte le masque
dans ces cas là y compris les petits
enfants j'ai lu que dix enfants
pouvaient pas le porter parce que ça des
lettres aux baptisés monde et
petits-enfants taiwan et à 5 ans il
porte le masque dans les bras de leurs
parents
sa quête personne et sur les règles de
d'obligations effectivement ils ont
varié dans le temps
mais pourquoi pas de confusion il y
avait d'une part l'organisation de
l'accès aux masques donc ça a été
convergente et manière assez strict avec
des dispositifs et applications sur les
téléphones etc pour gérer son stock
hebdomadaire est aussi savoir où on
pouvait s'approvisionner là où je veux
faire ma ci était approvisionné ou pas
ça a été très très organisés dès le
début dans personne ne s'y retrouver
sans masque et puis progressivement au
fur et à mesure que la production monte
effectivement les règles se sont
libéralisés et puis surtout aujourd'hui
on vit à peu près 100 masques par mois
dans l'ascenseur je suis un des seuls à
porter son masque encore aujourd'hui
parce que les gens dont les consignes se
sont allégées et les gens ont le
sentiment à tort ou à raison mais sans
doute à raison que le vide n'est pas
dans les rues voilà sur la question de
la coopération
il ya des bonnes et des mauvaises
nouvelles moi j'ai plutôt tendance à
avoir les bonnes nouvelles la visibilité
taiwan qui était peu connu un pour
beaucoup de gens taiwan la thaïlande
on va pas bien différent c'est bon
vraiment aujourd'hui tout le monde a
identifié taiwan et et pour de bonnes
raisons pour des raisons positives
donc il ya moi j'ai ressenti beaucoup de
curiosité et de partout après les
coopérations par exemple dans le champ
scientifique
mon expérience passée on a beaucoup
travaillé avec mon équipe là dessus mon
expérience c'est que on montre pas ce
type de coopération à chaud c'est à dire
que on a beaucoup de coopération avec
entre la france et taiwan au plan de la
recherche scientifique et universitaire
vraiment on a une coopération très riche
très diverses et pour laquelle les
scientifiques français qui viennent à
taïwan au 10 mai on a des partenaires
on est des gens qui sont un autre niveau
voire au dessus et qui ont des moyens
aussi
donc on travaille déjà mais sur la crise
elle même c'est un petit peu frustrant
pour moi parce qu'on a mis beaucoup on a
beaucoup sont des on est allé voir le
mhr et d'instituts de recherche etc
et puis l'inserm du côté français ou
d'autres organismes et ça n'a pas marché
mais mon nom mon pronostic c'est que mon
observation c'est que on ne monte pas ce
type de coopération à chaud et ceux qui
ont pu travailler très vite ensemble
c'est parce qu'ils se connaissaient déjà
et donc c'est sur la période normale là
aussi c'est de l'anticipation
il faut qu'on compte qu'on travaille à
développer ses liens et encore une fois
la visibilité la perception de taiwan
est très très améliorée donc je suis
assez optimiste
merci je vais poser donc je vais
demander aux commissaires de poser leurs
questions
on est trois qui sont inscrits nous
allons donc comme d'habitude les groupes
et angers le prix ville merci monsieur
le président merci messieurs pour vos
présentations très intéressante
moi j'avais d'abord une première
question parce que c'est un étonnement
chez moi vous avez parlé du traumatisme
du saas en 2003 or quand vous énoncez le
nombre de décès est ce que vous avez
expliqué que c'était l'histoire des
combinaisons genre fr spationautes qui
avait impressionné le les habitants de
taiwan
mais moi j'ai du mal à comprendre s
comme comment nous alors nous on n'a eu
quasiment quarante mille décès est ce
que c'est un traumatisme mais voilà je
suis récompensé un peu et puis après sur
la plus concrètement sur la production
des masques alors vous vous nous avez
dit monsieur casabonne que vous avez qui
a eu des machines
est-ce qu'elle était disponible en
allemagne visiblement il y en avait
immédiatement ou pas ça a mis combien de
temps est-ce que c'était anticipé ça que
du jour au lendemain on passe à une
production de masse en masse de masques
en masse est ce que à un moment donné
enfin j'ai eu l'impression qu'ils
n'avaient pas eu pénurie est ce qu'il ya
eu des moments de tension comment les
masques étaient distribués ou pas ou
est-ce que ça n'a pas eu lieu puisque il
ya eu toujours suffisamment de masques
est ce que ces chaînes de montage des
masques ont nécessité beaucoup de
salariés ou les à pouvait trouver parce
qu'il ya très peu de chômage comment
tout ça c'est l'agencé on a l'impression
que ça a été très facile
mumbai et nous en france ça n'était pas
donc voila c'était pour en savoir un peu
plus
et puis dernière chose parce que vous
avez évoqué le fait que
[Musique]
donc à taiwan c'est c'est évident qu'on
se protège en protège des autres qu'est
ce que vous pensez de du vocabulaire qui
a été notamment employée en france sur
les gestes qu'on dit barrière alors qu'
on aurait pu les appeler gestes de
protection et peut-être que alors je
sais pas comment vous les appelez
commence est appelé en fait à taïwan
est-ce qu'on donne un nom comme on a
donné nous sur ces choses là voilà je
vous remercie beaucoup et victoire
jasmin donc si monsieur le président je
félicite taiwan parce que si vous avez à
peine 500 cas et c'est une situation
exceptionnelle chez vous le voudrez
cependant savoir si vous avez fait une
analyse de la répartition par classes
d'âge et quelle est la part des
personnes âgées parmi les personnes
clients contractuels virus merci merci
je suis guide est oui merci président en
france l'armée française est intervenue
pour soulager les hôpitaux surtout dans
l'est mais aussi pour apporter leurs
compétences dans l'organisation d'une
médecine de guerre dans les transports
aériens
parmi les malades vers d'autres pays
vous avez parlé de votre armée
j'aimerais savoir comment elle est
intervenue sur votre territoire et pour
combattre cette pandémie dans quelles
conditions
merci merci damien regnard
merci je suis président je vais poser un
peu la même question que j'ai posée ce
matin qui m'intéresse au plus haut point
par rapport aux échecs patents en france
je voudrais savoir sur taïwan comment
fonctionne
l'arrivée et les départs des taiwanais
au niveau de l'aéroport
quels sont les restrictions est-ce que
vous avez mis en place un système de
test pour l'ensemble des passagers à
l'aéroport
et quelle est la procédure une fois
qu'ils sont testés s'ils sont testés
voilà sur la rive à tête merci merci
monsieur ou monsieur qu'il commence
alors j'essaie de répondre pour la
première question pour les gens qui ont
des traumatisés parce que il faut il
faut repenser en 2003 quand le sera
maintenant encore on a une image du
strass dont c'est un petit peu qu'est ce
que c'est le coronavirus mais celle
d'une forme d'hiver en 2003 on ne savait
rien du tout et on voyait des gens qui
étaient contaminés et qui mouraient tant
que même le nombre est d'être à l'imiter
mais c'était quelque chose qu'on savait
rien du tout on savait ça venait de
chine il ya eu beaucoup de morts à hong
kong aussi en france je pense qu'il ya
eu un cas où un mot c'était très peu
mais on assiste est très très différents
et très violent alors l'image et quand
je parlais bien sûr qu'on regarde c'est
le nombre des personnes or ce n'est pas
énorme mais quand c'est transit par la
télévision
l'hôpital qui était confiné et puis on
avait rappelé on avait rappelé des des
aides soignants qui savaient rien qui
s'est passé mais on avait peur que il
transmettait de pyrrhus ailleurs ont ils
rappelé hans rien savoir et on les a
combiné voyez on aime on les rappelle on
dit qu'il fallait travailler et vos plus
sortir et c'est pour ça qu'il ya eu des
suicides à l'intérieur parce qu'on
savait rien du dos il se passer c'est
comme on les laisser mourir et la
personne qui est des responsables entrez
dans une combinaison spatiale
j'ai encore tous ces images dans la tête
donc ces mises à ces images sont
vraiment traumatisé la population de
taiwan et après on a essayé de prendre
précaution et c'est comme ça dont on a
un qu'on a créé ce centre
ce centre de tri on a donc c'est il faut
repenser à ça maintenant ma connaissance
de médical un peu près 20 ans avancé
comme très différents donc je pense
il faut aider plan il n'y avait pas non
plus tout cette technologie peut suivre
des patients
donc là pour les gens à l'époque la
seule façon c'est peut-être de le mettre
de les confiner sur place et voir
comment ça se passe et je les avais des
amis ici et là dedans et après qu'elle
ait dû se faire soigner
psychologiquement pendant pas mal non
nous voilà non c'est pour expliquer un
petit peu ce qui se passait à l'époque
alors une autre question pour les
personnes il ya des choses que j'ai
oublié le personnage et comme il n'y
avait pas beaucoup de gens infectés dont
on n'a pas fait de on a pas de statut
spécial sur les personnages et il n'ya
pas non plus de protection spéciale pour
les enfants ou les personnes âgées
comment l'armée était intervenue sur sur
ces crises alors nous l'armée c'est au
début c'était vraiment sur la production
des matchs parce que dans la tête était
on est con on avait cette mémoire de
2003 donc comme gens vont venir porter
un masque
les masques pour se protéger pour d
autres c'était la première chose qu'on
pouvait imaginer
donc la chose la plus urgente de taïwan
bien sûr c'est d'arrêter le virus à la
frontière de n'est pas laisser des gens
qui est qu'on avait des doutes
contaminée pour entrer à tanger d'abord
les gens qui venaient de chine et
l'autre façon c'est vraiment d'augmenter
la production des masses comme je
voulais vous dire expliqué au début on
était on est des potes autosuffisante
on était comme la france dont dépendent
beaucoup des masses ou venant de chine
dont il fallait augmenter assez
rapidement et comment faire les gens
comprennent avait expliqué on
on avait essayé d'acheter des machines à
l'allemagne mais l'armée c'était surtout
pour aider la production pour parce
qu'on a eu on peut pas recruter
immédiatement des ouvriers et la
production pour concerne la main
d'oeuvre c'était plutôt facile et pour d
pour l'armée qui n'étaient pas
spécialisés sur ce sur ce coup-là
produisons donc l'armée était intervenue
de cette façon là alors un l'aéroport
pour déterminer qui arrivent et nous
nous les eaux regardez il ya une sorte
de doughty thermique qu'on pouvait
tester si on avait d'afir oui non donc
pour les personnes qui rentrent et dès
qu'il y avait de la fièvre il y avait
des percées médicales qui s'en charge et
on les envoyait bêtement aux hôpitaux
c'est vrai comme ça que ça se passe chez
nous donc odéon voici la première les
premiers symptômes c'est la fièvre et si
on a la fièvre
immédiatement on va les hôpitaux et bien
sûr après sert toute personne qui entre
et à taiwan devraient être confinés
pendant 14 jours
c'est vrai comme ça qu'on essaie devrait
pouvoir si les symptômes qui sortait
pendant les quatorze des 14e et si
jamais quelque chose arrive et on les
envoie immédiatement à l'hôpital ça qui
fait la différence avec la france c'est
que comme ils sont pas très nombreux
donc dès qu'il ya des symptômes qui
sortait l'hôpital prend en charge
immédiatement ils sont pas très nombreux
donc notre sécurité notre système de
santé pouvaient encore retenir si on
laissait des billets d'entrée à taïwan
je ne pense pas que notre système de
santé serait capable de tout c'est dur
de tout gérer comme en france je pense à
l'époque quand le virus est déjà rentré
on ne pouvait plus rien faire donc moi
je pense c'est le témoin a pu faire
c'est sévère gérer des personnes
limitées et comme ça dans le système
pouvait encore supporté voilà je sais à
peu près ce que j'ai dans la tête si
vous pouvez me poser je donne la parole
à jean françois qui pourrait me
compléter merci en france à alesi
monsieur si monsieur le président juste
pas complété en effet sur les masques il
ya eu des tensions il ya eu des tensions
au début février mars pour gérer la
pénurie
c'est à dire que le
le temps que la production monte en
puissance
donc là il ya eu des tensions pour pour
savoir où étaient les pharmacies où on
pouvait s'approvisionner
ou pour dire mais neuf masque pour un
adulte ou cinq places pour des enfants
c'est le pas suffisant par semaine donc
il ya eu des discussions publiques de
ceux de ce type là mais disons que
c'était plutôt autour de la gestion de
la pénurie
c'était pas du tout sur le principe et
c'était sur l'organisation de la montée
en puissance on a aussi vu malgré tout
nous pour les français qui vivent à
taïwan
surtout les jeunes des étudiants qui
était la situation un petit peu
précaires parfois un petit peu de mal à
avoir des masques on a vu des mamies
dans le but d'ouvrir leur sac et données
sont un masque
voilà et puis d'autres qui se met en
colère parce que c'est trop cher ben
avait pas de masque et oui ce genre de
mes ouvriers que c'est vraiment quelque
chose de collectif et donc pour sur le
point suivant gestes barrières geste de
protection c'est vraiment ça un geste
barrière c'est je me protège la geste de
protection c'est collectif est en face
d'une peau des dents a mis une stratégie
individuelle ça ne marche pas parce que
on est très inégaux en face du virus il
ya des gens qui tombent malades d'autres
pays ce qui marche c'est une action
collective et dans tous les débats que
moi je suivais avec horreur franchement
sur la pertinence de prendre la prise de
température dans les aéroports ou du
port du masque et c'est parce que ça ne
marche pas toujours
c'est pas la question c'est que ça
marche essentiellement ça marche
collectivement ça marche globalement et
c'est comme ça que ça marche
l'idée qui prévaut européenne un très
occidentale qui que on se construisent
la stratégie sur l'individu c'est un
contresens
je reculais ya un facteur culturel ou
même chose on a
appris à manger des sushis faire du judo
je pense qu'on apprendra à porter des
masques quand c'est utile
nous aussi c'est des choses on apprend
les uns des autres sur l'armée oui
effectivement je crois que l'armé a été
utilisée
juste pour le la mise en place des
chaînes de montage et le début de
l'engagement puis après c'est les
processus industriels s'est largement
automatisées qui ont été mises en oeuvre
et encore une fois ils ont acheté en
janvier donc en janvier il y avait des
machines parce que c'étaient les seuls à
acheter
c'est ça voilà et puis sur les
dispositifs jeu sur les classes d'âge
voulons c'est que les gens qui ont sont
décédés ou qui ont été pris avant
malades étaient des gens âgés et ou
affectées de pathologies très grave mais
on n'en sait pas plus
un terme aux statistiques merci il n'y a
pas d'autres questions vous avez été
convaincant dans vos réponses donc merci
en tout cas parce que c'est toujours
intéressant d'avoir pas un comparatif
mais l'expérience de pays tel que le
vôtre
merci à toutes et tous et nous à tapas
et a pas eu de précisions une petite
précision encore on a quelques minutes
sur eux sur l'aéroport wii à savoir si
chacun était testé quels étaient les
procédures disait alors il ya un
traitement différent pour les nationaux
pour les étrangers non je me suis un peu
plus intéressé aux étrangers donc il
faut il ya différentes catégories
par exemple avec une quinzaine de pays
pour lesquels la situation est
considérée comme
satisfaisante il ya une procédure
spéciale pour des gens d'affaires allégé
mais c'est vraiment très très ciblé et
de manière générale il faut quand on
entre dans la taiwan avoir un test pcr
de match 72 heures négatif évidemment
pour pouvoir rentrer donc pour pouvoir
monter dans l'avion en fait pour les
taiwanais je crois que mais je pense
tout en contrôle françois que l'accès
est évidemment ouverts mais que les
contrôles se font dès l'atterrissage est
d'ailleurs très souvent ça se voit en
lisant les journaux
ce sont les gens qui descendent de
l'avion et qui disent je crois que j'ai
un petit problème et se déclare
eux-mêmes voir des gens qui rentrent
pour se soigner notamment beaucoup
taïwanais qui était en chine
ils sont rentrés pour pour bénéficier du
système de santé taïwanais ont fait le
test mais après si jamais c'est on les
met en quarantaine
c'est vrai ça tu as fait et pour pour
nous voilà oui et pour nous étrangers
alors moi par exemple je vais être
soumis à une semaine de quarantaine
à mon retour la fin de semaine prochaine
et pour tous les nouveaux arrivants qui
ont pris leurs fonctions dans mon équipe
cet été avec leur famille ils ont été
une semaine en hôtel stricte spécialisés
ce sont des hôtels qui sont dévolus à ça
avec des taxis qui sont dévolues
également donc c'est un système qui est
extrêmement balisés personne n'est seul
et personne ne commet en principe ne
peut passer dans entrant entre les
mailles juste une anecdote
parce que là aussi les
les facteurs culturels il ya des
taiwanais qui sont pas disciplinés
qu'ils sont sérieux arrive comme partout
et cet été il ya un taïwanais qui
rentrait de l'étranger qui était en
période de quarantaine et qui a été
repéré parce que lille avait ressenti
une envie irrépressible de sortir et
aller au karaoké pour chanter voilà ça
serait pas ça se passerait pas comme ça
en france
il serait d'ailleurs oui et vous parler
qu'à vous parlez d'une quarantaine d'une
semaine ou de 14 jours alors il ya
différentes formules en fait au minimum
la semaine de quarantaine très très
stricte
là on doit être celle isolement et si on
a pas chez soi la capacité de s'isoler
du reste de la famille on doit aller
dans un hôtel spécialisés et ensuite
c'est de l'auto surveillance en évitant
les transports en évitant tout les
toutes les voilà en en étant une auto et
puis importants de masques en permanence
et c'est ensuite pendant deux semaines
c'est le règle générale genèse de ce
même à trois semaines en tout mais il ya
les mêmes questionnements actuellement
sur la bonne durée est ce qu'il faut
assouplir un petit peu est ce qu est ce
qui est le plus efficace
là je crois qu'elle est même débat que
qu'en france mais le le ratio stricte
aujourd'hui c'est une semaine de
confinement très très stricte
merci bien et ben écoutez j'ai levé la
séance merci en tout cas monsieur
voilà vous avez pu entendre les échanges
sur la situation à taïwan c'était dans
le cadre bien sûr des auditions menées
par la commission d' enquête du sénat
sur la crise du coc vide je vous
remercie de votre attention je vous
rappelle que vous pouvez retrouver tous
nos programmes sur notre site internet
publicsenat.fr
très bonne journée à tous
[Musique]